. Hello und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge. Danke an TobiZwei für dieses
fantastische, fantastische Intro. Einer der besten Tobis, die wir hatten bis jetzt.
Auf jeden Fall, der zweitbeste Tobi fand ich. Wir sind heute nicht allein, wir freuen uns
auf einen ganz besonderen Gast, endlich hat es, endlich hat es geklappt, seit Jahren baggern
wir daran, dass sie endlich mal in unseren Podcast kommt, lange keine Lust, jetzt hat sie Bock,
plötzlich, sie musste erst einen Bestseller-Roman schreiben, um endlich Bock zu haben. Hallo Julia! Hallo! Hey Julia, wir freuen uns sehr, dass du da bist. Ich habe gerade extra noch so Gelo-Revoice genommen für meinen Reiz. Wir machen heute keine Werbung. Heute ist keine Werbung vor. Ach so, sorry. Längst wieder weg. Ja, sorry. Ja, heute ist ein bisschen die Wrack-Folge, habe ich das Gefühl, jetzt nichts gegen dich persönlich, aber du bist heute reingekommen, hast Magenverstimmung, Verkrampfen, ich habe die Nacht nicht geschlafen, bin komplett am Ende, du hast gesagt, hier ist heiß, hier sind zwei Fliegen in deinem Bras geflogen. Nicht nur eine Fliege, sondern zwei. Aber es geht bergauf, ich habe gerade auch noch massive Probleme gehabt wegen Allergie, meine Augen angefangen zu brennen, jetzt habe ich aber eine Allergietablette eingeworfen und jetzt bin ich auf einem Hoch. Ich finde es aber auch mega, dass du sagst, dass massive Magenprobleme und dann aber Salsa-Tanzend in den Türrahmen stehst, während du das sagst. Ja, weil irgendwer von euch vielleicht diesen Migrenge-Beat gemacht hat und dann dachte ich mir, da kann man ja auch an mich halten. Aber Stefan hat ja letztens den Satz gesagt, dass er fühlt Musik einfach sehr, er ist einfach sehr zugänglich für Musik, er ist sehr sensibel. Das heißt, immer wenn man einen Beat macht, er muss tanzen, er muss sich bewegen. Auch mit einem schmerzversehrten Gesicht, ohne einen Arm oder mit massiven Magenproblemen,
ich glaube, ich will trotzdem tanzen.
Wenn ein Krankenwagen an uns vorbeifährt, einfach, du müsstest Stefan sehen.
Ich bin Tänzer, der DNA-Test hat auch gesagt, ich bin zwei Prozent spanisch und das merkt man, finde ich auch.
Oder nicht?
Hast du schon mal einen DNA-Test gemacht?
Nein, warum?
Ja, warum?
Warum?
Warum ist eine gute Frage.
In Deutschland kommt man halt auch aus Deutschland.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Und in Amerika ist das, glaube ich, echt spannend.
Und Warum? Ja, warum? Warum ist eine gute Frage. In Deutschland kommt man halt auch aus Deutschland. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und in Amerika ist das, glaube ich, echt spannend. Naja. Ey, wie geht's dir? Wie kommst du mit dem Ruhm klar, die beste Autorin zu sein? Ich bin gerade von dem einen Gebäude unserer Firma hierhin gelaufen, es war sehr heiß. Und es gibt ja diese schreckliche Kreuzung kurz vor der Brücke, wo die Autos aus drei Richtungen kommen. Und da habe ich schon so einen halben Kilometer davor gedacht, okay, du musst dich jetzt gleich konzentrieren, wenn diese Kreuzung kommt. Aber nicht, weil ich Angst hatte, dass ich irgendwie sterbe und meine Verwandten dann irgendwie mich vermissen würden, sondern weil ich gedacht habe, in zwei Wochen fliege ich in Urlaub. Und ich will das noch erleben. Und ich habe das immer kurz vor so Events, habe ich immer tierische Angst zu sterben. Deswegen sage ich mir dann immer kurz vor der Kreuzung, jetzt konzentrier dich, jetzt kommen von drei Seiten Autos und du willst nach Kreta fliegen. Ich habe vor kurzem, seit kurzem habe ich keine Angst mehr zu sterben. Ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt. Weil es dir einfach egal ist, ob du stirbst. Ja, du hast alles gemacht, was du machen willst. Ja, nö. Ich finde das aber ein guter Zustand, weil dann geht man irgendwie gelassen durchs Leben. Bei dieser Kreuzung, da war ich auch mal sehr nervös vor, weil alle da irgendwie an dieser Kreuzung meinen, das ist so eine wilde Westen-Kreuzung. Es sind auch keine Schilder und keine Ampel, da fahren einfach immer alle, wenn es passt. Und an dieser Kreuzung bin ich auch gerade lang gelaufen und ich bin einfach drüber gelaufen. Ich bin einfach drüber gelaufen, weil Leute halten schon an, die wollen ja auch niemanden umbringen. Und auch neulich war ich im Flugzeug und da waren Turbulenzen und ich dachte mir, ja, dann was das jetzt. Aber es ist doch eigentlich ein gutes Gefühl so. Man hat nicht mehr so viel Angst vor den Dingen. Ich weiß nicht. Wohingegen du noch in zwei Wochen kreden. Der Pfarrer sagt dann, aber danach ist mir eigentlich... Stammt nochmal, aber auch noch eins. Zwei Wochen, komplett alles gebucht, vier Sterne Hotel. Ich lese Ihnen mal die Helm-Rezensionen vor, was Sie noch hätte machen können. Nix davon. Es ist super, Schinken und Spargel gerollt. Aber mein Gott, es hätte trotzdem Spaß gehabt. Aber ist das nicht auch diese Brücke mit dem krassen Taub? Ja. Vor allem ist es immer so, weißt du, da ist halt wirklich die komplette Strasse darunter voll von Taubenmist. Und was aber auch so ist, weil dann kommt einer dir entgegen und den scheint es gar nicht zu stören, der ballert einfach durch. Und du denkst dir, jetzt bin ich dann der empfindliche Oder, der zwischendurch zwischen den einzelnen Häufchen und hersprungst. Wie auf dem Schulhof diese Hesten. Man muss sich so ein bisschen an das Niveau der anderen orientieren, weil sonst steht man, ich denke mir immer so, gut, wenn der da durchpflügt einfach, dann pflüge ich da jetzt auch durch einfach. Koste es, was es wolle. Deswegen ist es auch ein bisschen schwierig. Deine Birkenstabblasen sind schwierig. Warum gerade nach Kreta? Ich war letztes Jahr schon da und es hat sich herausgestellt, dass der Ort, wo wir waren, tatsächlich der perfekte Ort ist, um Urlaub zu machen. Das ist einfach relativ nah. Also ich habe einfach den perfekten Ort gefunden. Es ist irgendwie ein Sandstrand. Ich verrate dir niemandem, wie er heißt, aber es ist einfach ein Sandstrand, der ist karibisch, mit so türkisem Wasser, keine Steine, keine Tiere, keine Muscheln, keine Leute, sind nur Locals da, die da Urlaub machen. Die Preise sind irgendwie so 2004 stehen geblieben und man hat halt einfach komplett seine Ruhe. Aber was mit Abenteuer? Ja, Abenteuer pipapo, ich will einfach nur mich an den Strand legen und nichts machen, zwei Wochen. Das ist Urlaub. Das ist Urlaub für dich. Aber kannst du dich wirklich in den Sand legen und dann nach 20 Minuten nicht denken, jo, jetzt haben wir es auch. Kannst du dich wirklich den ganzen Tag einfach an den Sand legen? Ich kann mich den ganzen Tag an den Strand legen, von morgens bis abends. Das kann ich nicht gut. Komplett, auch bei 50 Grad, das macht mir nichts. Also wenn ich das, wenn ich den ganzen Tag Jahr am Strand verbringen wollen würde, dann müsste ich so einen riesen Beutel mit Frisbees und so und Beachbellen und diesen Holzschläger mitnehmen, um mich den ganzen Tag damit beschäftigen zu können. Ich kann nicht einfach fünf Bücher oder sowas. Ich nehme auf jeden Fall Bücher mit und dann tue ich immer so, als würde ich die lesen und lese dann aber eine Seite immer so zehn Mal, weil ich gar nicht lese. Wenn es sich um Sonnencreme verschmiert ist. Wirklich, und dann höre ich halt ein bisschen Musik und das war's. Das ist einfach perfekt. Aber dann hast du einen sandigen Handy an und dann... Ich habe extra so eine Hülle für den Strand fürs Handy. Ich nehme das dann auch mit ins Wasser und so. Perfekt equipped. Das ist wirklich mega. Ich hatte da als Kind immer so Probleme damit. Dann ist man so im Urlaub und dann freundet man sich so ein bisschen mit den Nachbarn an und dann sagen die Eltern, ja, geh doch mit denen jetzt zum Strand, damit wir unsere Ruhe haben. Und dann bist du mit wildfremden Leuten am Strand, fühlst du dich je schon schlecht und dann sitzt du da und entspannen die sich und dann denke ich mir, mein Gott, das ist so fucking langweilig und irgendwann holt jemand eine Frisbee raus. Ich denke mir, okay, jetzt passiert hier was mit einem Stück Pizza drauf, aber einfach die Frisbeescheibe als Teller benutzt. Ich dachte mir, das ist euer fucking Ernst. Kannst du mir den Kontakt irgendwie herstellen, wenn interessiert. Ja, schicke ich dir. Aber einfach so. Ich stelle mir auch einfach vor, dass die einfach nie verstanden haben, wofür man Frisbees dabei hat. Vielleicht hast du es auch nie verstanden, wofür Frisbees da hat, ganz ehrlich. Das stimmt. Deswegen gibt es ja jetzt die mit dem Ring. Ja, das stimmt. Mit dem Loch in der Mitte, damit man diesen Fehler nicht mehr macht. Wie so ein Donut. Damit man die Pizza nicht mehr da rein legt. Damit man die Pizza nicht mehr da rein legt. Wenn man die Pizza nicht mehr da rein legt. Wenn man die Pizza nicht mehr da rein legt. Wenn man die Pizza nicht mehr da rein legt. Wenn man die Pizza nicht mehr da rein legt. Wenn man die Pizza nicht mehr da rein legt. Wenn man die Pizza nicht mehr da rein legt. Wenn man die Pizza nicht mehr da rein legt. Wenn man die Pizza nicht mehr da rein legt. Wenn man die Pizza nicht mehr da rein legt. Wenn man die Pizza nicht mehr da rein legt. Wenn man die Pizza nicht mehr da rein legt. Wenn man die Pizza nicht mehr da rein legt. Wenn man die Pizza nicht mehr da rein legt. Wenn man die Pizza nicht mehr da rein legt. Wenn man die Pizza nicht mehr da rein legt. Wenn man die Pizza nicht mehr da rein legt. Wenn man die Pizza nicht mehr da rein legt. Wenn man die Pizza nicht mehr rein legt. Wenn man die Pizza nicht mehr rein legt. Wenn man die Pizza nicht mehr rein legt. Wenn so ganz kleine Frisbees, so kleine Gummis. So, da wollte ich auch noch zeigen, aber es ist auch sehr spannend. So kleine Gummischeiben und da sind dann, die wird in der Mitte wieder flacher und nach außen hin wieder zum Rand hin wieder ein bisschen dicker und dann kann man die so werfen und dann sind die sehr schnell unterwegs. Aha. Es ist wie so Baseballs, die man sich zuwirft, aber halt eine kleine Scheibe.
Aber das Ding ist halt, also bei einer normalen Frisbee bin ich schon so, dass ich, wenn sie fliegt, auf mich zufliegt, nicht sehe, wo sie ankommt.
Ja.
Und wenn dann noch die Sonne blendet, sehe ich gar nichts und mache dann irgendeine ganz komische Bewegung.
Aber wenn die noch kleiner sind, siehst du ja gar nichts mehr.
Ich glaube, das riecht sie primär ins Gesicht dann auch.
Und das ist auch wie so Hartgummi, ist dann auch nicht toll.
Und du kannst nur so eine ganz kleine Pizza da rauflegen.
Ja, das ist problematisch.
Vielen Dank. Siehst du ja gar nichts mehr. Ich glaube, das riss die Primär ins Gesicht dann auch. Und das ist auch wie so Hartgummi, ist dann auch nicht toll.
Und du kannst nur so eine ganz kleine Pizza darauf legen. Ja, das ist problematisch.
Zwei Prünktions.
Diese kleinen Piccolinis.
Piccolina!
Die Piccolini-Frisby.
Ich denke mir immer so, warum geht man da nicht den nächsten Schritt?
Weil wir haben eine grosse Pizza, jetzt haben wir neun kleine Piccolinis.
Piccolinisimus.
Warum nicht einfach 81, so wirklich zwei Euro Stück grosse, ganz winzige Pizzen?
Geil.
So dass es wichtig ist, große Pizza. Jetzt haben wir neun kleine Piccolini. Warum nicht einfach 81, so wirklich zwei Euro Stück grosse, ganz winzige Pizzen, so dass du wirklich die so wegsnackst einfach. Das wäre doch richtig geil, warum nicht einfach nochmal, die Menschheit macht immer einen Schritt und dann immer so, oh, dann setzen wir uns hin und mal hier ist eine Bank und oh, hier, guck mal hier, hier ist ein neues Projekt, eher so. Und jetzt können wir doch auch wieder zurück zum Auto gehen oder so.
Aber man kann nicht mal irgendwie kommen.
Der nächste Schritt auch noch, zu sagen, nee, wir machen nochmal neun hoch zwei Pizzen draus.
Einfach nochmal den nächsten Schritt.
Macht niemand.
Das finde ich geil.
Das wird man immer machen.
Piccolinissimus wäre das ja dann.
Ja, wir haben ja letzte Folge gesagt, dass die Menschheit als Gemeinschaft klug ist.
Und dass zum Beispiel, wenn ganz viele Menschen schätzen, wie viele Reiskörner in einem Glas sind, dann im Durchschnitt sind sie genau richtig, hat Stefan zumindest behauptet, ob das wirklich so ist oder nicht. Und wir haben dann irgendwie gespekuliert, bis wann ist es nicht mehr möglich, also irgendwie ab Milliarden Reiskörnern kann ja kein Mensch sich das mehr vorstellen. Und es gab viele Leute, die haben ausgerechnet, wie viele Reiskörner in eine Badewanne passen. Ja, Leute. Und haben uns das geschickt. Vielen Dank dafür, ich glaube es sind ungefähr 200.000. Echt? Danke, ja. Hätte jetzt aber gedacht, dass es mehr sind. Ich hätte gedacht, dass es weniger sind. Und wir zusammen sind wieder genau richtig gewesen. Deswegen kannst du dir auch Mathe sparen, du kannst einfach nur die ganze Klasse schätzt gemeinsam. Ist nicht die Erkenntnis einfach, die Menschheit ist ein gutes Team und es irgendwie auch eine schöne Erkenntnis ist. Wow, ich finde, wir sollten jetzt hier Schluss machen. Die Menschheit ist ein gutes Team, mit dir auch, gutes Team. Das wie bei Arrival habt ihr ja sicherlich gesehen. Ja klar, Arrival, toller Film. Das war auch einfach das Fazit von dem Film, oder? Nee, da waren alle dagegen. Hä, die sind doch letztendlich abgehauen. Die haben aufgerehalten, miteinander zu kommunizieren. Die haben doch, glaube ich, so zwölf. Die sind abgehauen, haben die Menschen in Ruhe gelassen, sobald sie anfangen haben, zusammenzuhalten. Ja, man denkt ja, die Alien-Invasion schweißt die Menschheit zusammen. In dem Film ist es genau andersrum. Am Anfang kommunizieren dann auch jeder miteinander, da wo die Alienschiffe gelaufen sind. Immer mit diesen Bildschirmen. Und irgendwann schalten die ihre Bildschirme ab. Ja, vor allem, als ob alle StaatsChefs immer miteinander skypen. In so einem weirden 36x36er-Chair. Und das konnte ich nicht durcheinander reden. Deswegen in jedem von diesen Inside-Alien-Filmen hängen alle bei Skype ab. Und vor allem würde jedes Land einen gleich grossen Bildschirm kriegen. Als ob China genau einen gleich grossen Bildschirm hat wie fucking Luxemburg. Wo du denkst, ja, sorry, was sagt Luxemburg nochmal, können wir ganz einfach alle mal ruhig sein, dafür zu hören, was Luxemburg sagt, ja, jetzt alle hören zu. Ja, vor allem, manche wählen doch auch immer diese Satire-Präsidenten, da ist der Nettensatz aber bestimmt der nebenan Island, genau, der irgendwie so einen Martin Sonneborn an dem Typen hängen gesetzt hat, also einen Clown einfach nur oder Schimpansen. Es ist lächerlich, ich glaube glaube die wissen auch ganz genau, dass es scheissegal ist, was sie denken. Ja, macht ihr das doch mal. Macht ihr das doch mal. Am Ende schalten alle ab, nur Luxemburg bleibt berühmt und dann so, ja. Wir würden doch kommunizieren und dann die Amerikaner auch so, ja, okay, macht ein Bildschirm aus. Wir fahren gerade in den Tunnel, sorry, ist ganz schlecht, ganz schlecht gerade. Ganz schlecht. Benutzt überhaupt noch jemand Skype? Ich bin jetzt auf Discord und so umgestiegen. Ich heisse nicht, benutzt du nur Skype? Ich habe ja Skype benutzt, weil ich jetzt zwei Jahre in einer Fernbeziehung war und da hat man halt ab und zu geskypt, aber ich finde es halt auch einfach irgendwie so ein bisschen old school. Wobei ich mir denke, wenn du ein Programm machst, das Skype ersetzen soll, Discord, dann musst du doch schon bei der Programmierung in Verben denken, weil Skype ist deswegen so erfolgreich, weil es ein gutes Verb ist. Hey, lass uns skypen, aber du kannst nicht sagen, lass uns discorden, so es funktioniert. Warum denkt man da nicht direkt mit bei der Entwicklung? Aber ich glaube, die denken eher ans Amerikanische und ans Englische, let's discord, let's skype. Ja, da kannst du alles sagen, let's pizza, du kannst jedes Wort so sagen, weil du hast kein Sprachgefühl für das Englische. Du weißt nicht, ob let's discord total fremdartig klingt für einen amerikanischen Sprecher-Mensch. Ich glaube, für mich klingt es toll, to Discord. Ja, aber du bist ja auch... Bro, für dich klingt alles cool, weil für dich alles Englische cool klingt. Let's Discord, yeah man! Ich habe meine Liste gemacht mit Themen für heute. Oh, wirklich? Okay, sorry, wir wollen... Wow! Sie ist sehr elaboriert. Okay, wir sind sehr gespannt. Shoot. Ich bin in ein offenes Brainstorming mit mir selbst gegangen und habe Themen ausgesucht. Ich finde gut, dass man jemanden mit einer Agenda reingeht. Wir wollen dich nicht länger aufhalten. Du musst das Lenkrad wieder in die Hand nehmen, Juliette. Also ein Punkt auf meiner Liste ist Florentin Cherry Coke Deep RTO Tour. Was hast du gesagt? Okay. Weisst du, wir waren verbündet auf der RTO-Tour. Ich habe noch nichts verraten, Florenzi.
Du kannst entscheiden, ob es erfüllen.
Das war so eine Erster-Welt-Krieg-Schützen-Graben-Beziehung zwischen uns, wo man einfach sagt, okay, wir stecken hier beide gemeinsam drin, lass uns das Beste daraus machen.
Und sie hat mir den Rücken gedeckt, während ich, glaube ich, so zwölf Dosen Cherry Coke aus dem Kühlschrank geklaut habe.
Und du hast es eigentlich gesagt, dass du es geheim halten willst. Bis jetzt.
Das Ding ist, also man muss sagen, du hast sie offiziell nicht geklaut, sie gehörten uns. Also es gibt ja in jeder Location gibt es ja Catering und das Catering war ja für alle aus dem Orchester da, auch für Floridin und mich. Und wie viel wir davon nehmen, das bleibt uns selbst überlassen. Das Ding ist halt, das Orchester hat halt jeden Tag Soundcheck gemacht und da waren wir halt überflüssig, weil wir halt nicht soundchecken mussten. Warte, nicht, pardon, aber die meiste Zeit überflüssig? Ja, ja, die war doch wegen eines Songs. Deswegen waren wir ja Verbündete, weil wir halt einfach so ein bisschen wie Aliens in diesen Bussen mitgefahren sind. Beim Soundcheck hat man von uns nur so das Geräusch gehört, wenn man eine Dose aufmacht. Okay, passt, Julia passt, Julia passt. Und ja, irgendwann bin ich während des Soundchecks, ich habe unten gehört, dass die Soundcheck gemacht haben, und bin dann so an der Küche vorbei, es war in Bielefeld, und gucke so nach links und sehe auf einmal Florettin, wie er mit seinem geöffneten Rucksack vorm Kühlschrank steht und die ganzen Dosen Cherry Coke in seinen Rucksack packt. Er war auch so im halb Dunkeln mit so einem angsterfüllten... Es war alles sehr hell erleuchtet. Und so ganz weit aufgerissene Augen und so ein... Also Rundfunk-Tanzorchester-Tour, die es jetzt nicht ganz gecheckt haben, wo wir gemeinsam gesungen haben, du und ich und die anderen noch eine kleine Band dazu und ja das war tatsächlich wir waren bei der ersten Location und es gab Cherry Coke und ich dachte mir, Alter diese Tour wird der Himmel, jeden Tag Cherry Coke trinken, nur bei der allerersten Location gab es Jerry Coke, danach nie wieder. Und deswegen war ich klug, dass ich mir zwölf Dosen gesichert habe für den Tourbus. Das war wirklich klug. Das Problem, wie lagert man Dosen in einem Bus? Legt man sie aufrecht, legt man sie seitlich, stellt man sie auf? Wohin fallen sie? Wohin fallen sie einfach, wenn eine Location steht? Dosen sind wirklich nicht so leicht zur Lage. Denkt man darüber nach. Ich habe mir da an diesem Tag noch in einem Geschäft ein kleines Regal gekauft, was ich in meiner Kajüte angebracht habe an der Wand. Weil ich hatte ja eine grössere Kajüte als alle anderen. Ich habe nämlich, das klingt jetzt erstmal abgehoben, aber es gibt vorne, ganz vorne über dem Busfahrer quasi das quere Bett. Und das ist höher, weil man hat kein Doppelbett, sondern es gibt nur da ein Bett, ein grosses. Über dem Busfahrer hat es ein Bett und es war halt ein Doppelbett, es war das einzige Doppelbett, die anderen waren halt wirklich so einer Betten und dann halt so ein Quadratmeter. Also die Betten waren alle im ersten Stock. Warum das Doppelbett auf solchen Locations? Ja, und ich hatte halt das einzige grosse Bett und da konnte man halt wirklich was verstauen.
Und dann habe ich da halt ein Regal angebracht an der Wand und habe da alle wichtigen Sachen... Wieso mit den Lägeln oder was? Nee, nee, mit so richtigen Panzertape und so. Also man durfte da natürlich nichts richtig verändern, aber ich habe es festgeklebt und habe dann da auch, habe es Florentin gleichgetan und habe Durstlöscher dann geklaut, weil ich bemerkt habe, dass es da auch Durstlöscher gab. Das war dann so mein Ding. Aber kann man, will man da schlafen oben über dem Busfahrer? Weil ich denke mir immer, wenn man irgendwo reinfährt, dann doch, dann bist du ja sofort. Ja, vor allem, du musst dir vorstellen, es war halt eine Fensterfront, an der ich geschlafen habe. Also es gab einen Vorhang, aber ich konnte halt nachts mal den Vorhang aufmachen, dann bin ich halt quasi über die Autobahn gefahren.
Wie toll ist das denn bitte?
Ich war als erstes am Bus, weil ich wollte den besten Platz, ich wollte das beste Bett, weil ich bin sehr empfindlicher Schläfer.
Immer!
Und deswegen, und ich habe den Busfahrer gefragt, aber ich bin clever, ich frage den Busfahrer, der kennt sich ja aus,
habe mich gefragt, was ist das beste Bett? Und er hat gesagt, das grösste Bett ist es direkt oben, aber das ist auch gleichzeitig das schlechteste Bett, weil man im 90 Grad Winkel zur Fahrtrichtung schläft, ja, also sozusagen senkrecht. Und dann, wenn der Bus Gas gibt und bremst, dann rollt man im Bett hin und her. Man rollt überhaupt nicht. Ich habe mir dann links und rechts so Bettdecken hingemacht, dass ich halt total so wie so ein Baby halt.
Ja, so hat der Busfahrer das erklärt. Man rollt überhaupt nicht. Ich habe mir dann links und rechts so Bettdecken hingemacht, dass ich halt total so wie so ein Baby halt.
Ja, so hat der Busfahrer das erklärt. Ich habe mir gedacht, ah, bin ich clever. Und dann habe ich schon gesehen, die Julia kommt und oh, ich nehme das Grössebett. Und ich dachte mir schon, ja, nimm dein grosses. Und ich habe schon die riesige Mausefalle gesehen, wie sie zuschnappt langsam. Und es war so geil in dem Bett. sagst, kannst du mit mir das Bett tauschen? Nichts, sah! Sie hat iminen Luxus gelebt und ich habe gelitten. Und jeden Tag bin ich eingeschlafen mit einem Auge auf ihre Kajüte. Neidisch. Ich habe das ja auch noch so geschmückt mit so Gelanden und Lichterketten und so. Und du hast Fotos geschickt an jeden aus der Band. Das war eine kleine Wohnung einfach. Aber es war halt auch ein bisschen eklig, weil es auch wirklich das einzige Bett ist im Bus, wo man Sex haben kann. Und in den Bussen fahren ja viele Rockbands, die dann alle da Sex haben, weil du hast halt Platz nach oben und du hast oben auch noch einen Spiegel an der Decke, wie im Puff. Also wirklich wie im Puff war es ein bisschen. Sagt man das denn dem Bett an? Ne, es war auch alles so abwaschbar, aber es hat sich so ein bisschen komisch angefühlt. Aber wie toll das ist, also ich stelle mir so Orte, hör auf jetzt. Du hättest es haben können, Florian. Ich weiss, deswegen ärgert mich ja so. Du musst auf deinen Bauchgefühl, nicht auf dem Busfahrer. Du bist eine Zecke, du bist dann auch, wenn wir nur in New York, er hat nichts mit der Vorbereitung zu tun, nichts. Ich buche die ganzen Sachen und am Ende ist er der Erste, der durch die Zimmertür huscht und sich das beste Schlafzimmer schnappt. Dieses Jahr nicht, mein Freund. Dieses Jahr passiert das nicht. Und wenn ich nicht herauszerren muss auf allen Vieren, das ist mir egal. Ich schlafe dieses Jahr in meinem besseren Schlafzimmer. Aber das ist wirklich toll. Ich finde es ganz schön, wie das beschrieben war, weil das stelle ich mir einfach den perfekten Schlafplatz vor. Es war tatsächlich für den Bus echt nicht so schlimm. Also es war recht gut. Ich glaube, die anderen tat mir dann auch irgendwann sehr leid. Könntest du die Sterne sehen? Nee, ich habe halt Autobahnlichter gesehen, aber ich habe jetzt nicht. Und auch Autobahnlichter in Himmel? Ich habe auch meistens den Vorhang zugezogen, weil ich auch schlafen wollte. Man ist ja auch kaputt dann. Ja, so langen Soundcheck. Aber wenn man so alleine auf der Autobahn ist und mal lange kein Gegenauto kommt, dann nicht mal so ein bisschen funkeln im Himmel. Gar nicht. Nee. Hattest du ein Fenster? Nee, kein Fenster. Kein Fenster? Es gab ja im ganzen Bus kein Fenster, nur halt vorne bei mir. So, können wir bitte dieses Kapitel beenden? Man kann sich ja ungefähr vorstellen, wie es da gerochen hat. Es gab Teppichboden und du konntest halt kein Fenster aufmachen. Und es war Winter und es waren ungefähr 20 Leute in dem Bus.
Und ich dachte mir, ich mache alles richtig und freue mich mit meinem Bettnachbarn an, weil es ja wichtig irgendwie so, ah guck mal, pass auf meine Schuhe auf und so. Und dann stehe ich auf und gucke, wer schläft denn über mir, ja, ist immer ganz wichtig, wer schläft über in, ich mache den Vorhang auf und wer schläft da, die Tuba. Über mir wurde die Tuba gelagert und mein Bandnachbar war eine Tuba. Aber ich dachte mir, ja toll. Aber es ist doch mega, es ist doch besser, als wenn irgendjemand da so stinkt und schnallt und so. Ist doch gut. Habt ihr geschnallt? Eben, ich dachte mir so nachts so, hallo. Ich habe mir auch immer vorgestellt, ich konnte überhaupt gar nicht schlafen in dem Bus, nicht gut. Und ich habe mir vorgestellt, dass wenn wir einen Unfall bauen, dass man einfach den gesamten Bus als einen grossen Sarg an so einem grossen Kran in so ein grosses Loch fährt und uns alle gemeinsam begräbt. Und einfach dann einmal so Erde drüber und dann so RTO, Julia und der Busfahrer und die Tuba. Steht auch die Tuba-Familie am Grab. Ja, oder so ein Tuba-Spieler ohne Tuba, der mit den Händen dann so und dann einfach die Beerdigung macht. Das ist nicht so schlecht. Ganz clever eigentlich, wir haben so ein Flugzeugabstuhl. Der fahrende Sack. ein Flugzeugabstuhl, ein Flugzeug innehmen. Das Flugzeug, man gräbt schon ein Loch ein und das Flugzeug fliegt direkt ins Loch rein. Das Grab einfach in Form eines Flugzeuges geschaufelt. Wer war der Erste, der auf die Idee gekommen ist, Leichen zu vergraben? Das war so ein Krankheitsding, oder? Irgendwer hat man gemerkt, ich glaube, das ist ein Geruchsding. Aber was war der erste Modus? Hat man die einfach noch am Tisch sitzen mitlassen oder liegen lassen? Keller vielleicht. Oder dann so, ach komm, die Oma setzt mal am Tisch. Erst hat man die doch einfach einbalsamiert, oder? Und einfach liegen lassen. Ich glaube, ganz am Anfang... Vielleicht war es einfach irgendwann zu viel und gesagt, Leute, die können wir jetzt nicht auch noch einsalben. Jetzt langsam müssen wir mal zurande kommen hier.
Aber was machen denn Affen? Die leben doch auch in so einem Stamm oder so einer Horde oder sowas.
Wenn da einer stirbt, dann...
Dann essen die sich, oder?
Werfen die denn weg?
Essen die sich nicht?
Essen die ihre Leiche?
Nein.
Ich will jetzt nicht so eine komische These aufstellen, aber...
Die lassen die zurück, die ziehen ja auch, ist auch ein wanderndes Volk.
Wirklich? Die wandern doch, die haben die Territorium, ich glaube, die gehen dann erstmal da weg und wenn sie wiederkommen, war es bestimmt ein Tier gegessen oder so. Trauern die auch? Ehrlich, ich habe mal gehört, dass Elefanten trauern. Also Schimpansen tragen dann nur schwarz. Aber wo ich mir denke, ihr wollt Emotionen ablesen von einem Rössel? Viel Spaß, mein Freund. Woher willst du wissen, dass er tra? Rössl hängt schlapp runter. Er hat einen reichen, die sich so ein riesen Taschentuch.
Der Rössl selber macht so. Schimpansen tragen ja in Trauerphasen dann nur schwarz.
Ja.
Sorry.
Da habe ich auch wiederholt, weil ich denke, der kam kam gerade nicht an, weil ein bisschen leil, ein bisschen laut.
Trauern wir? Ich trauer. Ja? Ich trauer häufig. So tote Promis, ist das ein Thema für euch? Ja, also es kommt auch an, auf die Promis an, aber bei Carrie Fishers Tod war ich sehr traurig. Ja, das stimmt, da war ich auch traurig. Da war ich sehr traurig, sonst passiert es nicht so häufig, dass ich traue Menschen. Ich habe jetzt schon Angst vor John Williams Tod. Ja. Weil da kann man, also wie gesagt, Musik ist ja sehr berührt mich ja sehr. Und dann kann ich dann, wenn ich dann... Ja komm, der hat doch irgendeinen John-Williams-Algorithmus entwickelt, der danach weiterlebt. So einfach für jeden Film der Welt. Stimmt, so eine AI kann man entwickeln. Wirklich. Ja, aber kann ich einfach jemand anders weitermachen und weiterhin klassische Musik klauen? Ich meine, das kriegt man doch hin, oder? Können die uns einfach nicht sagen, what? Wisst ihr, worüber habe ich überhaupt nicht getraut? Notre Dame. Ich auch nicht, ich fand das so scheiße. Ich habe keine Millisekunde über Notre Dame getraut. Ich fand das, am Anfang dachte ich so, oh, ist ja schon schade, das war das höchste der Gefühle und dann war es nur noch so richtig ekelhaft. Ich fand das ekelhaft, wie viel Geld, die haben die mit Geld beworfen, die können ja jetzt zehn neue in Notre Dame von bauen. Für ein scheiss fucking Kirchengebäude. Es ist dann für einen kurzen Zeitraum auf Twitter dann auch so die Diskussion entstanden, ob man da drüber Witze machen darf. Wo ich mir dachte, das ist ein brennendes Gebäude, da ist noch nicht mal jemand gestorben. Es waren Wen auf dem Dach, Bienenstöcke, selbst die haben überlebt. Die Bienen haben überlebt. Also wenn man nicht darüber Witze machen darf, rüber dann. Also lächerlich und dann wirklich, oh ich bin zutiefst bestürzt wegen den ganzen Kunstwerken. Nenn mal eins, nenn mal ein einziges Kunstwerk. Doch, die Krone von Jesus Christus, die Dornenkrone, die Dornenkrone von Jesus Christus, von seiner Kreuzigung, haben sie gerettet. Stopp, stopp, Aret, wo, also der wurde gekreuzigt und dann hat man dann vom Kreuz die Krone weggenommen oder was? Ja, hat die direkt UPS-mäßig nach Paris und dann ausgestellt. Ja, aber die Römer haben sich doch darum gekümmert, warum sollten die die Dornen von der Aufklärung aufgehen. Keine Ahnung, das ist einfach so eine Krone aus Dornen und die sagen, die gehört Jesus Christus. Dieses Leichentuch von dem ist ja auch nicht echt mit dem Gesicht drauf. Aber das ist ja ein Folterinstrument. Das ist doch alles nicht echt, aber... Das ist alles Bullshit. Alles kompletter Bullshit. Das war dann schön. Stell dir vor, Jesus kommt zurück und dann so, hier sind die Nägel vom Kreuz, die haben wir aufgehoben. Warum solltet ihr die aufheben? Die Schweine, die Krankenschweine. Dann sagt der, wo ist meine Krone denn? Und dann sagen wir, die ist uns da verbrannt. Ich habe eine Novelle geschrieben, wo ist die, ja die haben wir verloren. Die ganzen guten Sachen sind weg. Sind wir ein Album aufgenommen? Habt ihr das Album gehört? Ja, Beatbox. Ich habe neulich Bares für Rares geguckt und da wurde eine Rekordsumme erreicht mit einer Kette mit einem Kreuz und da drin war ein Stück vom Splitter vom Kreuz von Jesus Christus. Ein Stück vom Splitter vom Kreuz? Ja, also wirklich so ein Mikropartikel eigentlich von Holz, wo sie halt sagen, das hat ein päpstliches Siegel hinten drauf, das gehört hundertprozentig dem Kreuz von Jesus Christus an.
Nein.
Und haben das dann irgendwie für 70.000 Euro diesen Anhänger. 70.000 Euro. Was noch viel zu wenig ist, die wird das, also die Händlerin wird das einfach wahrscheinlich für Millionen verkaufen oder so, was total geistkrank ist. Aber ja, es sind Partikel vom Kreuz von Jesus Christus im Umlauf. Partikel vom Kreuz von Jesus Christus. Wahnsinn. Wo haben die das hingetan? Weil der würde doch dann in so einer Steinhöhle beendet. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich habe es immer noch nicht gecheckt mit dieser Steinhöhle. Man darf das nicht nachfragen. Ich denke mir immer so an Feiertag und dann habe ich so ein Quäntchen, was feiert man heute überhaupt? Und die haben den in der Höhle getan? Und dann hat der selber den Stein weggerollt? Warum? Wer hat den Stein davor gerollt? Beerdigen die jeden in der Höhle? Wie viele Höhlen haben die denn? Ich meine, er weiss kein Mensch. Wurde alles hundertmal übersetzt und wieder zurück übersetzt. Wir sind doch Christen alle. Warum beerdigen wir unsere Menschen dann im Boden? Ich würde gerne Menschen in Höhlen beerdigen und dann so grosse Steine davor rollen. Das ist doch fun.. Das wäre mega. Das war Spaß. Die gesamte Trauergemeinde arbeitet zusammen, packt zusammen an. Oh, jetzt. Komm schon, auf, Tante Erna. Perfekt. Und alle schieben diesen riesen Felsbrocken. Da kommt er niemals raus. Ach, jetzt haben wir den Rollator in der Höhle vergessen. Komm, noch mal alle zurück. Diese grossen Felsbrocken, die man nur aus Comics kennt, die habe ich auch in meinem Leben noch nie gesehen. Die haben perfekte Formen, so perfekt rund. Genau, vor diese Lochfassen. Schiebt man diese davor, finde ich supergut. Auch Obelix mit seinem Hinkelstein. Auch man hinterfragt als Kind auch nicht. Was ist das? Hinkelstein. Nur nicht hinterfragt. Gibt's das eigentlich wirklich? Das ist halt sein Job. Hinkelsteine? Ist das erfunden? Ich glaube, das klingt so, als ob es ein Thing wäre. Das ist so eine Art Stonehenge-Ding, oder, glaube ich? Halt so irgendwelche so, so wierden Okkulten. Für mich klingt das wie so ein Fantasiewort, Hinkelsteine. Steine, das wird schon irgendwas so keltisches oder sowas sein bestimmt. Waren das nicht Germanen, Asterix und Obelix? Ja, aber sind Kelten nicht Germanen? Ja. Guck mal, du hast doch Germanistik studiert, Julia. Ich dachte, das sind Griechen. Okay, wow. Du bist Autorin, Julia, da. Du bist veröffentlichte Autorin, du musst zumindest was darstellen können. Sorry, ich habe hören. Menhe ist eine aus dem Bretonischen entlehnte Bezeichnung für einen vorgeschichtlichen, hochragenden Stein Block, der auch als Hinkelstein bekannt ist. In der prähistorischen Archäologie bezeichnet das Wort einen länglichen Einzelstein,
der in vorgeschichtlicher Zeit
von Menschen aufrechtgestellt wurde.
Ach so, den nur hochgestellt.
Und dann war gut.
Warum, haben die das schon in der Hoffnung,
dass irgendwann Leute das mal schätzen,
dass sie einen Stein aufgestellt haben?
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Du hast Zeit, was machst du ohne Internet den ganzen Tag, nachmittags? Man will sich ja unsterblich machen. Ich glaube, das ist für die so ein Ding gewesen, das ist eine Form der Selbstverwirklichung. Aber niemand wusste, wer diesen Stein aufgestellt hat. Bestimmt haben die ja mal irgendwas reingekritzelten Namen oder so. P.S. war hier, so mässig. PS. Obelix.
Obelix.
Was ist noch da in der Liste stehen?
Erstmal wollte ich noch mit euch darüber reden,
ob euer Podcast wirklich Pufo genannt wird von Fans.
Pufo ist, glaube ich, eher kein Titel.
Manchmal. Also wir haben ja die Pufopedia
so und dann, glaube ich, Pufo. Also ich schreibe
auch manchmal Pufo, aber ja.
Ich wollte etwas fragen zu deinem Prozess des Romanschreibens. Ach du Scheiße. Wann war das, weil ich habe ja so ein bisschen die Entschädungskritz auch mitbekommen. Wie heisst der nochmal? Wer? Das Leben war ein... Das Leben ist... Ah, es war einmal das Leben. Es war einmal ein Julia Becker. Sorry, mir ist kurz die ISBN-Nummer entfallen, kannst du nochmal kurz... 1, 2, 7, 4, 4, 3, 2, 5, 7, 2, 5, 0.
Alles klar. Okay, sorry, ich war nur kurz zurück.
Okay, nee, das Leben ist eins der härtesten von Julie Becker.
Ich habe das in einem Zug weggelesen.
Hast du es wirklich gelesen?
Ich habe es wirklich gelesen, ich habe das in einem Zug weggelesen.
Und am Ende dachte ich mir, super Buch und so, aber muss ich dir jetzt nicht sagen,
aber du hast da so lange dran gearbeitet und dann saugt man das so an einem Nachmittag weg. Mega enttäuschend, da ist mega wenig bei rumgekommen. Aber wo ich mir auch denke, wie viel Zeit man konsumiert. Das habe ich jetzt auch bei der Serie hier auch. Also du hast da glaube ich so eineinhalb Jahre, zwei Jahre oder irgendwas dran gearbeitet und das habe ich in einem Nachmittag. Was konsumiere ich denn an zeitfremder Menschen in meinem Leben? Ich sauge ja ganze Universen auf an Arbeitszeit, die da reinfließen. Ja, exakt. Das ist total spannend daran wirklich. Aber du hast ja wirklich erst die Idee gehabt, quasi Kurzgeschichten zu schreiben, beziehungsweise kleine Slippets. Und wie ist dann die Idee zum Roman gekommen? Oder hast du dann mit dem Schreiben gemerkt, nee, ich will doch lieber in grossen Zusammenhängen eine Geschichte schreiben?
Also ich hätte mir persönlich nie zugetraut, einen Roman zu schreiben. Ich glaube, das war das Problem an der ganzen Sache. Ich habe von Anfang an gesagt, ich kriege nur Kurzgeschichten hin, vor allem. Warum? Weswegen? Ich habe halt einfach gesagt, Roman ist halt einfach so serious, also es ist so serious business, da musst du halt wirklich was schreiben, damit es nicht total scheisse ist und da musst du dich halt wirklich hinterhängen mit viel Zeit und viel Aufwand und ich habe halt Vollzeit gearbeitet und ich habe halt gesagt, nebenher schreiben schaffe ich das nicht, ich müsste mich da komplett reinhängen. Ja. Dann habe ich halt gesagt, ich kann nur Kurzgeschichten schreiben. Wenn das okay ist, dann mache ich das mit dem Buch so.
Und das war auch okay und ich habe auch Kurzgeschichten geschrieben und ich habe die auch eingereicht und so. Und meine Lektorin hat halt dann gesagt so, sorry, aber irgendwie das ist alles so phantasievoll und so, das wäre echt schade, wenn das jetzt Kurzgeschichten bleiben. Und dann haben sie halt gesagt, schreib einfach einen Roman, du kriegst das schon hin. Hast du dann quasi neu angefangen oder waren die Kurzgeschichten auch schon grundlegend?
Ne, ich habe neu angefangen und die haben dann wirklich gesagt so, ja, du kannst einen Roman schreiben, wir stehen hinter dir und so, du schaffst das schon, aber gib uns doch bitte bis, keine Ahnung, in zwei Wochen eine Romanidee. Und ich so, ja klar, schaffe ich kein Problem, habe ich gesagt. Und das war wirklich der absolute Untergang, weil ich habe wirklich keine Idee gehabt, die gut war, die irgendwie neu war.
Alles war irgendwie schon 15 Mal. Das ist ein Problem, habe ich gesagt. Und das war wirklich der absolute Untergang, weil ich habe wirklich keine Idee gehabt, die gut war, die irgendwie neu war.
Alles war irgendwie schon 15 Mal da gewesen und ich wollte aber auch nichts Langweiliges machen aus meinem Leben oder jetzt auch kein feministisches Manifest, weil das alles irgendwie schon gerade so da ist. Und dann sass ich halt wirklich im Zug nach Reinweg zu Rowold und hatte halt eine richtige Scheissidee.
Und ich wusste auch, dass sie scheiss ist und ich wusste, ich muss jetzt gleich an so einem Tisch, an so einem... im Zug nach Rheinweg zu Rowold und hatte halt eine richtige Scheissidee.
Und ich wusste auch, dass sie scheiss ist und ich wusste, ich muss jetzt gleich an so einem Tisch, an so einem Konferenztisch einfach Leuten von Rowold eine Scheissidee pitchen und muss da so tun, als würde ich es selber gut finden. Und ich habe mich so geschämt auf dieser Zugfahrt, dass ich halt wirklich die ganze Zeit zur Notbremse geschielt habe. Oh, jetzt habe ich hier was kaputt gemacht. Ich habe die Notbremse geschielt und habe so gedacht, ich habe in meinem Kopf so gedacht, was passiert eigentlich, wenn ich die ziehe, so muss ich dann irgendwie ins Gefängnis oder so, alles irgendwie besser als jetzt zu Rowol zu fahren und eine Scheissidee zu püchen, läuft das eigentlich noch, das Mikrofon habe ich zerstört. Ja, ja, ja, das ist krass. Okay, und dann habe ich das gegoogelt, Notbremse ziehen, Kosten und so. Und so langsam hast du mir eine Geschichte in deinem Kopf zurück. Genau, und dann habe ich halt einfach gedacht, okay, ich schreibe einfach eine Geschichte über eine Frau, die eine Notbremse zieht, aber gar kein Geld hat, um das zu bezahlen. Und dann stand ich in Hannover, als ich umsteigen musste und habe das dann so panisch in mein Handy gesprochen. Eine Frau zieht die Notbremse, hat aber gar kein Geld und dann muss sie so viel zahlen, es geht ein Unfall und sie wandelt das dann in Sozialschuld um. Und irgendwie drei Stunden später war ich dann bei Rowold und sass am Tisch und hab denen diese Idee mit so einem erstaunlichen Selbstbewusstsein gepitcht und die meinten, das ist mega. Geil. Und ich so, okay. Ja, habe ich zwei Wochen dann gearbeitet. Ich fand das wirklich toll, dass ich irgendwann gehört habe, dass du einen Roman schreibst, weil ich dachte die ganze Zeit, wenn man das so mitbekommt, wie Autoren von irgendwelchen Late-Night-Shows oder mit einem guten Triller-Account angesprochen werden und die ganzen Verläger jetzt auch quasi mit solchen Leuten Geld machen wollen und ich immer das Gefühl habe, die haben einen engen Zeitplan und die werden ein bisschen ausgebeutet und am Ende kommen halt so langweilige Klolektüren raus. und das fand ich immer so, finde ich einfach immer blöd. Das ist kein Mehrwert. Und ich finde das dann richtig cool und finde es auch mega beachtlich, dass du dann so einen Roman geschrieben hast, auch, ja, und jetzt quasi das dramaturgische Wissen drauf geschafft hast und so, und es ist ja auch eine coole Zusammenhänge, eine geile Geschichte geworden ist. Ja, es wundert mich auch immer noch, dass das funktioniert hat, aber... Das ist schon echt cool. Ja, ich hatte halt auch mega Angst davor, dass es so ein Klo-Buch wird, einfach so ein, was mir selber so in zwei Jahren spätestens peinlich ist. Ich glaube, es ist die erste Geschichte, die ich kenne von jemandem, der angesprochen wurde und vorher noch nicht, du warst ja jetzt, du bist ja nicht raus in die Welt mit, ich will einen Roman, sondern du wurdest ja angesprochen, weil du auch hier bei mir im Magazin schreibst und so. Und ich glaube, das ist das erste Buch, was mir gefallen hat, was aus so einer Genese entstanden ist, glaube ich. Ja, ja. War dann der Schreibprozess ähnlich, dass du in den letzten zwei Wochen dann irgendwie 80 Prozent des Buchs geschrieben hast, oder war das eher ausgeglichen? Nicht in den letzten zwei Wochen, aber auf jeden Fall in den letzten drei, vier Monaten. Also das ging ja über insgesamt zwei Jahre, bis es fertig war. Und das ist jetzt nicht, dass ich da zwei Jahre dran gesessen habe jeden Tag, sondern ich bin halt montags bis freitags arbeiten gegangen und habe dann am Wochenende geschrieben und morgens vor der Arbeit und abends nach der Arbeit dann in der heissen Phase. Und ja, in den letzten drei, vier Monaten ist eigentlich fast alles entstanden. Ach, crazy. Hast du die Geschichte vorher so am Reissbrett überlegt oder bist du beim Schreiben? Nee, beim Schreiben einfach. Ich habe einfach drauf losgeschrieben und dachte, okay, so panisch habe ich drauf losgeschrieben, dachte, okay, Katastrophe, Katastrophe, Katastrophe und dann hat meine … Du gucken, wo man landet. Ja, ich habe das dann immer so zwischenstoppmäßig meiner Lektorin gegeben und gesagt so, ist es eine Katastrophe und sie meinte immer so, nee, mach einfach weiter. Und das hat mich dann auch das Teil von uns. Ich hatte so, mach einfach weiter. Mach so ein Babysitter dann quasi. Ja, ja, schon, den braucht man auch. Den braucht man auch wirklich. Man kann es dann anrufen und die sagt dir dann, nö, auch alles gut. Eine weinende Schuld ist es nicht. Man darf das nicht unterschätzen, weil wenn man das erste Mal einen Roman schreibt, das erste Mal in deinem Leben und du sitzt ja wirklich ganz allein vor deinem Laptop so, du hast kein Korrektiv oder irgendjemand, der dir hilft oder sagt, das ist lustig, das ist scheisse, das hört sich komisch an, sondern du bist ganz alleine und du musst selber nach Gespür ein Buch schreiben, was am Ende funktioniert. Und das war teilweise wirklich schwer. Das verstehe ich aber nicht bei Tarantino und solchen Leuten, wo man ja auch mal denkt, dass sie alles alleine schreiben und so.
Ich glaube, es gibt keinen Menschen mit einem guten Korrektiv, der sich selber gut religieren kann und so.
Ich glaube auch, dass solche Leute vor allem davon leben, dass sie coole Freunde haben oder ich glaube, da schätzt man total das Umfeld von solchen Leuten, die dann auch mal sowas lesen und gut darin sind, Feedback zu geben. Ich glaube, dann Christopher Nolan, wenn er dann so ein Buch schreibt, ist auch erst mal scheiße. Ja. Und da muss man, ich glaube, das ist auch total wichtig, sich das nicht zu unterschätzen, dass man da ein gutes Korrektiv um sich herum aufbaut. Aber das ist ja interessant. Dann hilft die Lektorin einem ein bisschen durch die taffe Zeit. Ja, die sagt dann einfach, alles gut, bist gut on track, ist alles gut, mach dir keine Sorgen. Und dann schreibt man erst mal wieder weiter und dann meldet man sich wieder und sagt, ist es jetzt eine Katastrophe? Und dann sagt sie, nee, schon okay.
Schreibst du das in einem Buchprogramm oder hast du einfach in Word geschrieben? Ich habe nicht Word, sondern dieses Pages. Wahnsinnig unseriös. Das ist immer wahnsinnig, weil das nicht aussieht wie ein Buch. Ja gut, aber wie ein Buch sieht das eh nicht aus, bevor es ein Buch ist. Ja eben, ich bräuchte so eine App, wo das dann auch schon aussieht wie ein Buch. Kannst du die Schriftart selber aussuchen oder ist es immer die gleiche Schriftart ein Buch? Ich habe da tatsächlich überhaupt nicht drüber nachgedacht. Kannst du nicht sagen, mach nochmal ein bisschen grösser. Mach nochmal ein bisschen, weil der Text ist gross, relativ gross. Ja, weil sonst wären es wahrscheinlich 30 Seiten reinen Text. Nee, du hast ja schon eine Menge geschrieben. Aber die machen, dass der Text immer grösser wird und am Ende ist nur noch ein Buchstabe pro Seite und man liest, kommt richtig schnell voran und denkt sich, ojojojojo, jetzt geht es aber aus, wo die verschlingen das Buch herförderlich. Bücherwurm. Du hast aber meiner Meinung nach einen sehr grossen Fehler begangen, denn du hast, so wie ich das verstanden habe, Referenzen auf echte Personen in dein Buch geschrieben, so kleine Anspielungen. Und das ist natürlich ein Strudel, aus dem man glaube ich nur noch schwer rauskommt. Weil wenn du jetzt dein nächstes Buch schreibst, ich glaube Science Fiction wird es sein, mal wieder, ich weiß noch, die hast du noch nicht viel verraten, da wird natürlich jeder drauf lauern, so und, kommen da auch so zwei Podcaster vor, ein Kluger und ein Dicker, Kannst du da nicht irgendwie so ein lustiges Duo machen, irgendwie so oder sowas in der Richtung, weil dann sind alle enttäuscht, wenn sie nicht vorkommen. Was hast du denn da für Erfahrungen gemacht? Der Cameo von Hitchcock. Ja. Denkst du, die Leute freuen sich, wenn sie ein Buch vorkommen? Ja, natürlich. Klar, das ist so eine riesige Ehre. Und dann deine beste Freundin kommt dann so und so, ich bin der unsympathische Chef oder wer bin ich oder was? Und die fühlen sich dann plötzlich ganz komisch auf, machen immer verrückte Dinge, damit sie im Roman landen. Ja, genau. Ja, ja. Oder sterben, bringen sich um, damit du es ihnen widmest oder so. Der letzte war ich im Zug mit so einem Schaf und dann hat das da ein Lamm geboren im Zug. Und ich war geburtstisch. Verrückte Geschichte, oder?
Ich habe das da rausgeholt mit den eigenen Händen.
Ja, genau. Und ich hatte nur die Servietten vom Bahnenbistro und so.
Und dann dachte ich mir, was frisst so ein Lamm?
Ja, verrückt, oder?
Kannst du in dein Buch schreiben, wenn du willst. Kein Problem.
Mach ruhig, mach jetzt meine Karte.
Schreib ruhig. Ich habe es schon mal aufgeschrieben, hier.
Ja gut, ich freue mich auf die Zukunft, was meine Freunde so machen, um im Buch zu landen. Aber hast du schon das nächste Buch in der Pipeline? Du, das Ding ist ... SWR hat gerade nur ein anderes Buch. Ich habe natürlich kein Buch mal ebenso in der Pipeline, aber ja, ich glaube, es ist angedacht. Du brauchst, dass du die Zugfahrt zu Rowold. Ja, so eine panische Zugfahrt. Das brauchst du einfach nur.
Und dann hast du die nächste Idee. Ja, vielleicht. Obwohl ich war neulich bei Rowold, aber das ist mir nichts eingefallen. Warum warst du da? Einfach nur auf Spaß? Einfach nur so. Ich wollte da mal das neue, die sind ja umgezogen nach Hamburg. Und du wolltest einfach mal sehen, wie sich so eingerechnet haben. Ich wollte mal gucken, wie es da so aussieht. Spektakulär. Ist das so ein cooles Startup-mässiges Office? Nee, das ist so ein dreiecksförmiges Gebäude, wo in der Mitte aber nichts ist, nur so fällt man halt so runter. So ein Lichthof. Das heißt, man kann so außen... Lichthof heisst das? Keine Ahnung. Ja, kann sein. Improvisieren. Okay. Man kann nur außen rumgehen, so dreiecksmässig, dass es interessant ist. Und sie haben so eine Maschine, die Leitungswasser zu Sprudelwasser verwandelt, was ich mega finde. Solow Solostream? Nee, nicht sowas, sondern direkt aus dem Hahn raus. What? Das finde ich so next level. Es kommt aus der Leitung als Sprudel raus. Geil. Und viele Schreibmaschinen und Leute dahinter? Nee, aber es gibt einen Hund. Es gibt einen Rowold-Hund. Rowold-Hund? Er ist schon sehr alt, glaube ich, aber sehr nett. Wie viele Exemplare hast du von deinem eigenen Buch? Kriegt man da so eine Kiste?
Ja, man kriegt am Anfang irgendwie, ich glaube, ich hatte 30 oder so.
30?
Oder 50? Kriegt man einmal. Ich glaube, das muss man einfach mit denen verhandeln, wie viel man davon bekommt.
Und verschenkt. Du wurdest bezahlt in deinen Büchern.
Ja, und dann bekommt man von jeder neuen Auflage zwei nochmal zugeschickt, um zu gucken, ob alles okay ist. Zwei aber dann auch. Zwei von jeder neuen Auflage. Also ab und zu kommen immer zwei Bücher nochmal an. Aber warum auch? Ich meine, stellst du die so normal in dein Regal und dann kommt jemand vorbei und dann dein Bücherregal einfach so fünfzigmal dein eigenes Buch, so drei rein? Im Moment ist es tatsächlich so, aber ich versuche die halt alle zu verschicken, irgendwie, dass sie wegkommen, weil das fühlt sich nicht richtig an, irgendwie aufs eigene Buch zu starten. Ihr könnt heute nämlich, fünf Hörer von euch haben die Möglichkeit, ein Buch zu gewinnen. Jeweils fünf Bücher. Können wir es echt bitte verlassen? Ja, können wir machen, wenn du willst, klar. Ich habe wirklich noch zehn Bücher oder fünfzehn zu Hause. Ja, ihr könnt auch Heavy and German Shit machen. Ja. Ja, okay, schreibt uns, fünf von euch bekommen ein Juliaths tolles Debütbuch, ein preisgekröntes Debüro-Mann geschenkt. Ja, wirklich? Wir müssen übrigens zum Studium von Nachwuchspreis. Dankeschön. Einen der renommiertesten Preise, die es ja überhaupt gibt hier in Deutschland. Die zwei Personen in diesem Raum schon abgestaubt haben. Wahnsinn. Herzlichen Glückwunsch, Stefan, nochmal. Hast du, dass du dieses coole Marmor-Ding bekommen hast, es ist auch eine große schwarze Stein.
Ja, und jetzt pass auf, es ist mir natürlich kaputt gegangen. Echt? Also es ist Folgendes passiert. Ja. Florentin, jetzt nur ganz kurz. Lass mal kurz. Ist jetzt keine Erfolgsgeschichte, ist eher das Gegenteil. Ich habe diesen Preis gewonnen, hat mich sehr gefreut. Kannst du deinen Roman schreiben, was jetzt kommt? Und ich bin ein sehr unsozialer Mensch, was so Networking, Veranstaltungen, Smalltalk und so angeht. Das ist einfach nicht so meins. Und nach der Veranstaltung wollte ich halt so schnell wie möglich mit diesem Preis zurück nach Hause. Und bin dann wirklich nur noch ganz kurz geblieben und dann bin ich gegangen. Und am nächsten Tag musste ich halt mit dem Zug von Hamburg nach Köln und dann bin ich auch dreimal umgestiegen. und es war 500 Grad und ich war zu spät und hatte den so im Jutebeutel liegen, diesen Marmorpreis. Und der hat schon so die ganze Zeit so geklackert, da dachte ich so, scheiße, aber ich hatte jetzt auch nicht die Zeit, den da rauszuholen irgendwie. Und da war eine Ecke abgebrochen und jetzt steht er halt in meinem Regal mit einer abgebrochenen Ecke und dann krieg ich gestern tatsächlich vom Studio Hamburg so eine Karte geschickt, wo drinsteht so, liebe Julia, wir haben dich leider nicht mehr gefunden nach der Veranstaltung, wir wollten dir doch noch deinen Case geben für den Preis, damit du den transportieren kannst. Warst du auch keinen Case bekommen? Und haben wir gestern dann dieses Case so gepolstert mit Seide geschickt und dann ich so, ja, zu spät, aber danke. Aber was erwarten die denn, welche abenteuerlichen Reisenden ihre Gewinner machen, dass man da ein extra gepolstertes Case braucht? Habe ich auch nicht bekommen, welche. Dass sie wirklich irgendwie in ihr Flugzeug steigen. Ja, offensichtlich mit dem ICE von Hamburg nach Köln, reicht das schon, um den zu zerschmettern. Marmor? Ja, Marmor, verrückt, oder? Der ist echt schick. Das ist echt schön. Schicker Preis, muss man sagen. Könnte ich mir befehlen. Macht sich gut in Wohnungen. Ja, aber wichtiger sind ja so die, nicht die materiellen Dinge, sondern so, was man so erreicht hat. Aber habt ihr nicht auch mal einen Podcastpreis gewonnen oder so, zu zweit? Ja, in den deutschen Podcast. Ja, in der Praxis kann die Thaisa den. Ach ja, stimmt. War es ein schöner Preis oder? Das wissen wir nicht, den musste Thais fragen. Ach so, habt ihr den direkt weitergegeben? Ne, Thaisa hat den für uns abgeholt. Sie wollte eigentlich auch einen Podcast machen, aber passiert nichts. Wir wollen halt alle, aber im Endeffekt, wer macht es am Ende? Warum hast du noch keinen Podcast? Ich würde gerne einen Podcast mit Thais machen. Ja, das ist doch super. Wo ist sie eigentlich jetzt gerade? Hat sie einen Raum, wo sie arbeitet? Ne, nebenan hört sie ab wie so das Leben der anderen. Sie ist jetzt niemals im Serverraum und guckt. Der Serverraum, in dem Axel wohnt. Sie schreitet nur ein, wenn irgendwas passiert. Verstehe. Schneidet sie euren Podcast? Ja. Macht sie echt, ne? Unbezahlt? Oft dann fügt sie die Effekte drunter. Nein, nein, das Praktikum ist beendet. Ach so, sie ist gar nicht mehr da. Nein, die war nur zwei Wochen da. Wo ist sie denn jetzt? Was 16-jährige Mädchen so machen, die ist wahrscheinlich unterwegs. Auf Snapchat.stehe. Weiss nicht genau. Oder protestiert gegen den Klimawandel. Man konnte übrigens von dem Büro von Rowold runtergucken auf den Platz, wo die Fridays for Future waren und da haben die sich gerade formatiert, als ich da war und hab dann so von oben so, yay, ihr seid klasse, macht weiter so. Ich mich bei euch, riesiger Beutelklasse. Dann so den Sprudel aus dem Wasser angeholt, das war mega. Lustigerweise hat CO2-Tank nochmal aufgedreht, komm, gib mal nochmal mehr Sprudel. Ich war neulich bei einem Familienzusammenkommen und da war meine kleine Cousine auch da, die ist auch 16, 17 Jahre alt und jetzt kam es dann auch dazu, zumächstehema Fridays for Future und sie hat erzählt, dass sie nicht hin durfte, weil ihre Mutter es verboten hat. Was? Meine Tante. Und da habe ich erst einmal mit meiner Tante geschimpft. Deine Tante ist ein neoliberales Arschloch. Ich habe mir geschimpft und dann habe ich aber auch zu meiner Cousine gesagt, so funktionieren auch offene Demonstrationen nicht, dass man sich von Eltern oder jemandem, gegen den man protestiert, verbieten lässt, auf eine Demonstration zu gehen. Du, du kommst daran, hat sie immer auch gesagt, dass sie da hingegangen ist. Sie hat mir dann erzählt, dass sie doch ohne, ohne, ja, ein Verständnis da war. Das fand ich dann sehr gut. Hast du gerade deine Cousine gesnitcht hier live im Podcast? Ja, aber meine Tante hört es nicht, aber meine Cousine hört den Podcast, von daher, wir sind in einem Boot, zwinker, zwinker, aber meine Tante hört den Podcast ja nicht. Liebe Grüße an der Stelle, mach weiter so, ihr macht eine gute Sache. Ja, ist eine gute Sache. Und die in Carmen eigentlich? Nee, in Dortmund. Ich habe ja früher mal, ich habe das Gefühl, der Witz ist ein bisschen untergegangen, ich habe dich ja früher immer mal gefragt, ob du und deine Kumpels früher die Carmen Geis waren. Die Carmen Geis, das sind diese Referenzen, die ich oft nicht verstehe. Mittlerweile verstehe ich Carmen Geis. Endlich haben wir eine echte professionelle Autorin hier. Man merkt es. Der hat so lange geschlummern, dieser Witz. Und das hat mich wirklich mitgenommen, dass du den damals nicht so... Ich habe das damals nicht so verstanden, weil ich habe versucht, zu lachen darüber, weil ich das Gefühl geben wollte, ich habe es verstanden. Habe ich nicht verstanden. Jetzt mittlerweile weiß ich natürlich, wer Carmen Geis ist. Jetzt, wo du Netflix machst, guckst du auch mal RTL 2. Ich gucke auch mal RTL 2, weil ich kein Netflix mehr gucken will, ja. Ne, Carmen Geist, finde ich sehr lustig. Okay, gut, haben wir das auch abgehakt. Die Carmen Geist zu nennen. Kam nicht so gut an. Nee. Aber du bist zu Hause, das ist deine Welt, diese Referenzen, dieses Late Night. Ja, absolut. Ich habe so einen Premium-Account für TV Now, für die ganzen Sender, RTL und so, aber man muss dazu sagen, ich gucke jetzt nicht diesen kompletten Müll wie Berlin Tag und Nacht oder so, sondern ich gucke hauptsächlich Goodbye Deutschland, wo halt noch so im Kern noch was Wahres dran ist, wo nicht alles gescriptet ist. Und das gefällt mir einfach. Ich finde da einfach immer lustige Leute für die Inspiration. Goodbye Deutschland. War da nicht auch der Typ her, der, hast du mir nicht erzählt, du erzählst ja, wenn man dir einen Comedypreis ist, zeigst du immer auf Leute und sagst, oh, das ist Malle-Jens, oh, das ist Carmen Geist. Ditch, der ist gestorben, Malle-Jens ist tot. Ach ja, stimmt, ach ja, richtig. Ich möchte jetzt hier um Peer-Ted bitten. War das nicht der, der auf Mallorca Klimaanlagen verkauft hat? Ja, genau. Nicht Klimaanlagen, sondern Heizungen.
Heizungen, genau, wo ich darüber lachen musste, weil das klingt einfach nach der dümmsten Idee der Welt.
Das klingt wie im Auenland einen Schulladen aufmachen.
Der hat auch seinem Geschäftspartner einen Finger abgesägt vor laufender Kamera und das war ganz schlimm.
Und später kam es dann zur Aussprache mit der Frau von dem Verwundeten und sie hat ihn zur Rede gestellt und er ist panisch wie er war aus dem Fenster gesprungen und geflohen vor laufender Kamera. Das gibt es nicht. Doch, das ist wirklich so passiert, das ist wirklich so passiert. Das könnt ihr alles nachgucken, wenn ihr einen TV Now Account habt, ich kann euch meine Login-Daten nehmen. Machen wir keine Werbung, Julia. Entschuldigung, von diesem … Es gibt es bestimmt auch auf YouTube, oder? Mallorca Jens, Malle Jens. Aber nicht der, der den Finger verloren hat, hat ihn konfrontiert, sondern die Frau davon. Der Typ lag ja im Krankenhaus. Ach so, okay. Der hatte ja wirklich einen Finger verloren. Welchen denn? Das weiss ich nicht, aber schon einen wichtigen Glauben, einen wichtigen Arbeitsfinger. Aber es gibt doch sozusagen drei von zehn Finger, die man gut und gerne verlieren kann. Jetzt mal unter uns. Zehn sind schon locker zwei, drei zu viel. Mein Gitarrenlehrer, erzähle ich immer gerne, mein Gitarrenlehrer hatte einen Finger halb verloren, den einzigen Finger, den man nicht zum Gitarre spielen braucht. Geil. Rechte Hand, kleiner Finger. Ja, bei so einem schönen Ring. So eine Seite weniger an der Gitarre. Aber selbst wenn kannst du dir doch so ein... Er hat sich dann aus Frust eine Seite abgeschnitten. Nie wieder geh! Und dabei ist dann der andere Finger einfach langgegangen. Aber fand ich super. Da haben wir die, mit der ich im Unterricht war, die haben gesagt, ist dir mal aufgefallen, dem fehlt ein Finger. Und ich so, nee. Ja. Das war das einzige, was wir jemals wieder gefahren haben. Vor allem, dass dir das nicht auffällt bei der Gitarrelehrer. Der immer so, so geht Fingertechnik und die einfach so, dem Film fehlt. Aber dem haben so zwei, also der Finger besteht ja aus drei Teilen und ich glaube zwei waren weg von drei. Zwei Doppel. Zwei Doppel. Zwei sind drei Parts. Und dann hat sie auch so gesagt, ich habe gewonnen, dass er gar kein Gesicht hat. Und du auch so nö. Worauf achtest du denn dann? Noch creepiger sind ja wirklich Leute, die einen Finger oder einen Zeh zu viel haben. Zum Beispiel Drew Barrymore hat sechs Zehen an jedem Fuss. An welchem? An beiden. An beiden? An beiden. An beiden sechs. Nice. Das finde ich voll geil. Aber welcher ist dann doppelt? Ich hat die einfach einen? Jeder Zeh hat ja einen eigenen Charakter. Ja, vielleicht haben wir auch alle einen zu wenig, ne? Das kann auch sein. Aber die sind ja nicht zwei grosse Onkel, zwei Daumen-Zees. Ne, ich glaube eher unten bei den Kleinen ist da noch sowas. Aber der reizt sich ein, also der nicht oben raus einfach. So ein Mittelfinger, oder unten raus immer. Aua, nee, ich glaube, das ist eher ein kleiner. Hast du irgendwas Weirdes am Körper, irgendwas untypisches, hast du ein Zeh zu wenig? Nee, ich glaube, ich bin eigentlich ganz gut so zusammen. Normal. Normaler Mensch eigentlich. Ich habe eine seltene Blutgruppe. Ja? Ja, B-negativ. Nur zwei Prozent der Menschheit. Also wenn ich verblute, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit gering, dass ich... Will man ja nicht haben eigentlich, ne? Ja. Ich habe Gallensteine. Echt jetzt? Echt? Ja, aber mein Arzt hat mir schon, glaube ich, als ich fünfzehn war oder so, hat er gesagt, ja, wenn Sie aufhören Herr Will, sie haben Gallensteine und das Problem ist ja, Gallensteine sind nicht so das Problem, aber die können irgendwo in so eine Öffnung reingehen und dann irgendwas verstopfen. Also ich stelle mir das so, wie wie so ein grosses Waschbecken, wo Wasser drin ist und da ist so eine Brötchenhälfte drin. Und wenn man Glück hat, dann läuft das Wasser halt aus, ohne dass die Brötchenhälfte den Ausschluss verstopft. Aber wenn man Pech hat, dann saugt die sich da fest. Und er meinte so, ja, wenn das passiert, dann verspüren sie messerstichartige Schmerzen und dann müssen sie ins Krankenhaus. Und seitdem rechne ich jede Sekunde meines Lebens damit, Zitat, messerstichartige Schmerzen zu heilen. Aber hatte ich dann auch in meinem Magen, ehrlich gesagt. Aber woher weiss man denn, wie sich ein Messerstich anfühlt das ist dann wirklich so ich glaube das weisst du wenn du das spürst ja dann denke ich mir ah das muss das wird es wohl sein das wird es wohl sein aber ich finde es so gut für diesen fünfzehnjährigen jungen die weggelassen hat so jede sekunde kann es passieren jetzt oh oh oh ne doch nicht doch nicht meine Schwester war im Krankenhaus weil sie irgendwie irgendwas mit einem Blinddarm hatte. Das ist eine grössere Schwester.
Eine grössere Schwester, die wohnt in Frankreich. Das merkt man bei dir. Und wieso merkt man das? Weiß ich nicht. Ich habe aus meinem Film gesehen, dass da die andere Charakterin gesagt hat, man merkt, dass du eine grössere Schwester hast. Ich habe auch noch einen grösseren Bruder. Ja? Aber keine kleine Schwester, ne? Das merkt man nicht so. Wieso? Den Bruder merkt man gar nicht. Gar nicht. Sieht man den Null an. Gar nicht. Also es würde mich nicht wundern, wenn du den Null geträumt hast.
Also meine Schwester hatte mal den Blinddarm, irgendwas war mit dem Blinddarm, ich weiss nicht mehr genau, ob sie entzündet war oder so, auf jeden Fall war sie im Krankenhaus und hatte Schmerzen, dass sie dachte, sie stirbt. Und dann stellte sich raus, dass da Teile von so Eierschalen und so, dass das da reingegangen ist. Deswegen sagt sie immer zu mir, wasch deine Eier. Das sagt meine Schwester immer zu mir, sonst wirst du irgendwann den Todesschmerz erfahren. Aber wascht eure Eier? Die hat den Blinddarm rausgenommen bekommen deswegen. Aber wie kommen denn Eierscheinen in den Körper überhaupt? Ich habe keine Ahnung, wenn da so kleine winzige Stücke noch dran sind und du das aus Versehen isst. Ja, aber wie gross redest du? Die werden halt nicht verdaut. Winzig winzig oder schon so, oh das muss weg. Winzig, nee winzig. Winzig winzig. Ja, deswegen wasch deine Eier, Florentin. Wasch deine Eier? Bevor man sie aufmacht, oder was? Bevor du sie isst. Oder beim Rührei, wenn dir aber was reinfällt, eine Schale rein, rausfischen. Ach, du meinst das gekochte Ei noch mal waschen. Ah, ja, ja. Oh ja. Ja, das ist ein guter Tipp eigentlich. Das ist ein richtig guter Tipp. Ich wusste nicht, dass sowas funktioniert, dass die Eierschale dann irgendwie ihren Weg, aber anscheinend ist sie resistent. Aber in der Sinn, dass man sich nicht verdauen kann. Ich finde, es macht schon Sinn, weil es einfach nur reines Kalk, keiner Kalk ist oder nicht. Ja. Der Körper ist ja nicht... Der Blinder war verkalkt. Wahrscheinlich war es das. Aber das kann man doch verdauen, oder? Du kannst auch Fingernägel verdauen.
Es gibt Leute, die ihre Fingernägel essen, und was passiert dann damit?
Ja, das weiß ich nicht, im Gegensatz zu dir.
Naja, ich gehe davon aus, dass was vom Körper kommt, geht auch zum Körper zurück. Oder?
Alte Regel.
Ich weiß nicht. Haare? Wären Haare verdaut? Auch nicht. Weiss ich nicht. So, aber nicht Kalk. Ich glaube, Kalk hat der Körper nicht so viel zu bieten. Ich glaube, das hat der Körper auch, weil das weiss ich jetzt nicht. Top-Tipp, Spülkasten entkalken. Toilettenspülkasten entkalken. Ich habe es am eigenen Leib erfahren, alles verkeimt, alles verkrustet, die Spülung halt nicht mehr aufzulaufen. Genau das Problem habe ich auch gerade. Genau das gleiche. Ich drehe jetzt immer das Wasser ab, für das komplette Badezimmer. Aber brauchst du da einen Schraubenschlüssel oder kannst du da... Nein, nein, ich kann einfach so einmal drehen. Aber manchmal vergisst man es halt und dann ist man am Wochenende weg und das Wasser läuft durch. Exakt, du kommst nach Hause und das Wasser läuft und denkst dir, ja gut, dass du so einen Kostenverbrauch hast, einmal durch rotiert, einmal durch deine Wohnung. Das ist wirklich der Spülkasten von den Vorbesitzern. Da denkt man nicht dran. Nee. Aber ich denke mir, also eigentlich heisst es, man muss da die Einzelteile rausnehmen, ich baller einfach den ganzen Spülkasten mit dem Kalkzeug dazu. Nein, man muss weg und neu. Ich habe das versucht, das hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert, das war so krass kalkig. Ja? Du hast dann diese einzelne... Vor allem weil das Wasser halt so kalkig ist in Köln, ne? Also das ist halt das grösste Problem. Da kommt halt auch die ganze Zeit nur Kalksuppe durch, seit ein paar Jahren, ein paar Jahrzehnten. Aber du musst die dann die Einzelteile rausnehmen, oder was, und die dann einzeln in so einen Topf entkalken, oder wie meinst du? Ich habe es bisher noch nicht geschafft. Ich drehe ja immer das Wasser ab.
Ich musste, glaube ich, einfach mal einen neuen Spülkasten kaufen.
Das ist mir in Chicago passiert, in einem Apartment.
Da ist plötzlich, da war einfach, die haben keine Spülkästen.
Da läuft einfach, das läuft einfach, die haben keinen Spülkasten.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie es läuft, aber das wird dann so runtergesogen.
Und dann kommt Wasser nach unten, so einem grossen Basin. Hast du da ein Wasser? Und dann hat das nicht aufgehört zu laufen und dann ist es übergetreten. Aber in einem Tempo, wo man sagt, gut, in 20 Sekunden ist die ganze Wohnung voll. Dann habe ich die Tür zugemacht, Handtücher vorgelegt und dann bin ich runter ins Rezeption gelaufen und habe gesagt, da ist ein grosses Unglück, hell of a unluck, passiert da oben und dann haben die mir so einen hauseigenen Klempner geschickt, der dann das repariert hat. Der dann zum Schnorchel in die Wohnung gekommen ist. Und die habe mir so vorgestellt, weil das war oben im 43. Stock oder das war lächerlich hoch, ich habe mir so vorgestellt, wie man dann mit dem Aufzug runterfährt oder hochfährt und die Aufzugtür so hoch aufzieht und dann so ein Pfuh, einfach der 43. Stock durch ist. Aber hat dann funktioniert und hat die ganze Wohnung ganz übel gestunken. Da war ein Kollege von mir vorher. Oh Gott. Das war eine ganz unangenehme Situation. Bei mir hatte jetzt die zweite Freundin innerhalb von einem Jahr eine Ratte, die das Klo kam. Oh, was? Das ist richtig krass. Also in Köln immer am besten den Deckel runtermachen, weil die durch die Rohre reinkommen, wenn es sehr stark regnet und die halt durch das abwassen. Ja, aber muss man die schon rauslassen. Wenn es die Ratte bis zu dir in die Wohnung geschafft hat, dann würde ich die schon rauslassen. Die eine Person sass halt auf dem Klo, als das passiert ist. Wow. So, das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Das habe ich mir mit den Pfefferkörnern gesehen. Und da kommt halt so ein Kammerjäger, ne, dann, ja. Das habe ich damals bei den Pfefferkörnern gesehen, da wurde Vite in den Arsch gebissen von einer Ratte und seitdem habe ich Angst davor, aufs Klo zu gehen. Also wenn es sehr stark regnet draußen... Ich glaube, das ist gerade mein Leben ruiniert mit dieser Information, dass es möglich ist überhaupt.
Eine sogar BTF-Mitarbeiterin hat eine Ratte im Klo, die dann in die Fünfer-WG geraten ist. Ja, okay, aber stellt euch die Situation mal aus der Perspektive der Ratte vor. Wie scheiße es der geht. In einer Fünfer-WG. Also was die hinter sich hat. Oh, Regen, what, Hilfe, oh, ich bin unter Wasser sofort in die Menschen. Platsch, Platsch, Platsch, Rat, sofort weg, wird weggespült, klettert sich todesmutig durch irgendein stockdunkles Rohrgewirr, kommt raus, auch nicht der schönste Anblick, und dann kommt noch ein Kammerjäger. Ich finde, wenn es sich so weit geschafft hat, kann man die schon zumindest empfangen. Zumindest mal Hallo sagen. Hey, hey, Ratte, auf den Wohl. Ich glaube, wenn man nett auf die zugeht, dann passt das schon. Soll ich dir ein Glas Kaffee, Glas Wasser? Ja, ein bisschen Milch, Kondensmilch, ein kleines Tütchen. Kondensmilch, bach, sagt die Ratte dann. Weiss ich nicht, keine Ahnung, was Ratten fressen. Ja, weiss man eigentlich. Ja, eklige Sachen, weil es eklige Tiere sind. Die überleben ja auch im Atomkrieg. Ja. Nee, Kakerlaken überträgen. Und Ratten. Ratten auch? Ja, sagt man. Wahrscheinlich schon. Wahrscheinlich überleben Ratten und Kakerlaken. Dann ist es hier ein unangenehmer Planet, ehrlich gesagt. Deswegen weiß ich gar nicht, ob ich in Atomkrieg überhaupt gewinne, ob ich in dem Land sein will, dass den gewinnt. Weil, stell dir mal vor, das ist dann das Ergebnis. Ratten und Kakerlaken. Wie gesagt, ich bin bereit zu sterben. Hast du noch was auf deiner Liste stehen? Du hast dir viele Gedanken gemacht. Nicht, dass wir was vergessen. Moment bitte. Ich bin gespannt. Ich habe nur so ein paar Themen, die ich halt dann einwerfen kann, wenn es mal wieder stockt. Ah, Reborn-Bubble, das ist ein sehr grosses Thema. Reborn-Bubble? Reborn. Reborn-Bubble? Ja, ich habe mich vor einer Zeit, gestern hat mich ein Mitarbeiter wieder darauf gestossen, habe ich mich mit so einer Bubble beschäftigt auf YouTube, die richtig, ich sag mal nett, verrückt ist. Es gibt so eine Bubble von Frauen, die sich lebensechte Puppen kaufen und die dann behandeln wie Kinder und dann quasi so Mami-Vlogs machen und die dann halt auch wirklich behandeln, wie echte Menschen mit denen sprechen, denen halt auch Zimmer einrichten und die halt wirklich richtig viel Geld ausgeben für alles, was Kinder halt so brauchen. Die wickeln die, die kaufen Windeln. Als Vorbereitung oder wirklich all in? Nein, all in. Das sind halt meistens wahrscheinlich Frauen einfach mit einem unerfüllten Kinderwunsch.
Aber denken die wirklich, das ist ein echtes Kind oder spielen die einfach so, als hätten sie ein Kind? Ich sage, dass sie es spielen. Also ich hoffe, dass es so eine Art Roleplay ist einfach, wo es ihnen sehr gut beigeht, weil sie halt traurig sind, weil sie keine Kinder kriegen können oder so. Aber das ist teilweise halt gestern habe ich ein Video entdeckt, wo eine Frau halt eine Wassergeburt gefilmt hat, aber sie hat dann eine Puppe geboren.
Und das war, ja, also Wassergeburt-Videos sind ja eh schon so, hu, dass man so aus Versehen mal so da draufklickt und dann so denkt, was habe ich gesehen?
Aber das war halt eine Puppe und sie hat halt wirklich auch so getan, als hätte sie richtig Schmerzen und hat dann halt so aus dem Wasser so eine Puppe gezogen. Aber das ist doch wirklich der Punkt, wo sich der Mensch vom Naturwesen vollkommen verabschiedet. Wenn der Mensch sich damit zufrieden geben kann, eine Puppe als Kind zu haben, also den jetzt evolutionären Sinn der Fortpflanzung, komplett aushebelt und sagt, ich habe alle positiven Seiten des Kinderhabens, irgendwie fürsorgliche Gemeinschaft und so, muss das Ding aber nicht füttern und irgendwie, keine Ahnung, zieht auch nicht aus. Also da kann man sagen, wir haben es jetzt geschafft schon langsam. Wir haben das Tiersein abgeworfen, weil das würde kein Tier der Welt machen. Der Moment, wo so eine Alienrasse kommen sollte und sagen sollte, so und das war es. Ja, das war es jetzt auch. Jetzt reicht uns, kommen wir kurz alle zusammen, so geht es jetzt nicht mehr weiter. Ihr fangt wieder von vorne an. Ja, dann drücken die so einen Knopf und dann kriechen wir wieder aus dem Wasser. Das Ding ist halt auch, die bleiben halt nicht zu Hause mit den Puppen, sondern die gehen halt wirklich raus und die packen die dann in Kindersitze, die sie gekauft haben und gehen dann ins Freibad zum Babyschwimmen oder so und auf dem Spielplatz und und zum Einkaufen haben die dann so ein Maxi-Cosi im Einkaufswagen und da liegt dann halt ein Baby drin, was wirklich aussieht wie ein schlafendes Baby, aber halt einfach aus Silikon ist. Kommen Leute und sagen, oh. Ja, und das passiert halt. Die werden halt darauf angesprochen, was ich dann halt auch so weird finde, wie man dann reagiert, wenn man sagt. Sagen die, ist das eine Puppe? Das ist eine Puppe. Aber spielen die dann auch das Kind, also wenn das Kind dann am Spiel spielt und dann... Also tönt die dann so... Wie mit so einer Actionfigur oder... Nee, nee, nee. Liegt das dann einfach verregungslos im Sand? Das Kind reagiert halt einfach nicht. Aber zum Beispiel bei dieser Wassergeburt hat sie dann einfach so mit iMovie Kindergeschrei drübergelegt, als es dann rauskam. Ach ja, ach geil. Und das war dann so ein bisschen echt. Die Menschen sind so ruiert. Ich war am Wochenende in Berlin ab einem Filmfestival, und das war wirklich das seltsamste Filmfestival, auf dem ich jemals war. Es war ganz, ganz leer einfach nur. Alle Kinos waren immer leer. Und dann bin ich da reingegangen in den Film, und dann waren da in einem Film, der lief es dann schon, drei Leute saßen da. Aber so klischee-mäßig ganz verteilt voneinander. Und der einzige, den ich richtig sehen konnte, war ganz vorne und der wurde von der Leinwand vorne angestrahlt, ich war ganz hinten. Und es war ein Typ mit einer Handpuppe in der Hand. Was? Ja. So ein Typ? Sascha Grammel. Nein, das war so eine ganz, keine mit, keine mit, keine Sascha-Grammel-artige Charakter. So eine kleine, für Kinder so. So eine Socke. Oh scheiße. Die so aussah wie er, auch mit so einem Anzug an. Und da saß er in der dritten Reihe, genau direkt zentral vor dem Ding, und die ganze Zeit neben ihm guckte der andere Kopf hoch. Und ich dachte mir, das ist jetzt, das ist mit einer der seltsamen Momente, die ich jemals erlebt habe. Und da saß er die ganze Zeit so. Und die ganze Zeit hat er dann die Handpuppe manchmal ihn angeguckt, wirklich? Manchmal, meistens nach vorne auf den Bildschirm gestartet. Oder auch Popcorn gegessen. Hat auch Popcorn gegessen. Wahnsinn. Das war unglaublich. Musst der manchmal die Hand wechseln, wenn die müde wird oder so, oder hält der die Illusion auf? Danach habe ich dann auch mal versucht, weil ich konnte ja nicht mehr auf den Film konzentrieren, klar, nur auf diesen Typen mit der Handpuppe. Und da habe ich das auch versucht manchmal, wie lange würde ich das aushalten? Man hält schon länger aus. Ja, auf einer Lehne auf jeden Fall. Kann ja machen. Mich würde interessieren, was das für ein Film ist, den Leute gucken, die mit einer Handpuppe ins Kino gehen. Das war eine Serie, das war eine holländische Serie, die war ganz okay, ging um Drogen.
Ist jetzt so dein Ding, ne? Das ist mein Ding, ja. Ich brauch mehr. Getypecastet den Rest des Lebens schreibst du Drogenserie. Ich nehm noch Drogenserien. Ne, war sehr uninteressant, aber ich weiss nicht genau, wie es die Handpuppe gefallen hat. Aber ich finde Handpuppe eh gruselig. Aber das ist ja anscheinend... Puppen generell einfach. Ja, dieser Wunsch von Menschen, sich eigene Menschen zu kreieren, irgendwie auf diese Art,
oder Dinge hinein zu projizieren. Das ist ja auch genau das mit diesem Reborn. Ja, aber es nimmt halt so krasse Aus... Machen das nur Frauen oder machen das auch Männer? Also ich habe bis jetzt nur Frauen gesehen, die es gemacht haben. Aber es gibt auch Männer, die haben dann Freundinnen als Puppen. Ja, eine hat auch einen Freund und die gehen dann halt auch einfach fahren zu dritt in Urlaub und so. Ja, aber es gibt auch Männer, die haben dann eine Plastikpuppe als Freundin. Ach so, ja, das ist ja nochmal was anderes. Aber es ist dann auch einer mit diesen Mundern, diesen aufgerissenen Glasern. Also ich habe mich da jetzt nicht groß informiert, aber ich glaube, da gibt es auch Geschmackfreundere. Ich glaube, es gibt so richtig leb inzwischen. Ich bin mir vor, dass man so ein Date hat, ging immer vom Restaurant, ist immer dieser aufgerissene Mund. Aber wie ist das mit Essen? Also bestellen die dann Essen für die und dann nimmt der Kälte das einfach wieder mit oder isst der dann für zwei? Die Puppen sind ja wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr realistisch und sehr lebensecht und die werden auch in so einer Fruchtblase geliefert. Also die packen die aus und dann müssen die das so aufstechen und dann kommt da so ein Baby raus, was wirklich aussieht wie ein Baby, erschreckend, echt. Und dann haben die die halt als Kinder und manche haben halt so fünf, sechs davon, eine kostet keine Ahnung, tausend Euro oder so. Aber ist das dann so ein Abo-Modell, dass du alle sechs Monate ein neues kriegst und das wächst dann sozusagen?
Irgendwann kommt diese Frau mit dem Blasen im Mund.
Irgendwann, Mama, ich zieh aus.
Jetzt zieh endlich aus, ich kann nicht mehr.
Wirklich so, du kannst dir ein Kind kaufen und das wirklich dann auch so und dann ist dann auch ein Autor, der überlegt sich dann Sachen,
oh, jetzt ist es in der Schule, gab es einen Zusammenstoss mit Paul, irgendwie Schlägerei, der überlegt sich die Backstory zu dem Kind und du kriegst alle sechs Monate eine neue Puppe, die dann wächst dann immer und dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, die Punkphase, dann hast du irgendwie so rote Haare oder so, ist doch genial.
Ja, und mit 18 an der Mund.
Ich glaube, die verkaufen halt ihre, wenn sie gelangweilt sind, verkaufen die bei Ebay oder so oder in diesem Forum von Reborn-Babys und kaufen sich da eine neue, wenn es mal wieder Zeit für ein neues Kind ist. Ein grösseres Rundell ist. Das sind immer aber Neugeborene. Nee, es gibt auch so drei- bis vierjährige oder so, die dann halt wirklich schon so sitzen können und so. Also es ist wirklich, und die machen dann halt auch so Reviews für so zum Beispiel Windeln oder so. Ja, mit denen komme ich ganz gut klar, von Rossmann und so. Und ich denke so, ja, das ist mir klar, dass ich damit gut klarkomme, da passiert nicht viel. Das ist absurd. Es tut mir auch teilweise leid, aber dann denke ich wieder so, die sind irgendwie mega happy so, dass dann irgendwie eine alleinstehende Frau, die keinen Freund hat, aber dann irgendwie sich so ein bisschen so familiär wenigstens so tun kann, als wäre sie eine Mutter. Das ist doch perfekt. Eigentlich tun sie ja keinem weh, es ist nur ein bisschen creepy, mit so einer Puppe durch die Gegend zu rennen, wo Leute dann denken, da schläft ein Baby. Dann vergisst man die Puppe mal im Auto, weißt du, so eine lebensechte Puppe bei 40 Grad. Da schmilzt die. Da steht er aber ganz schnell. Annetta! Komplett über dem Beifahrersitz. Schmilzt die Elektronik frei und so. Ja. Mama, ich liebe dich, liebe dich, liebe dich, liebe dich, lieb, lieb, lieb. Und dann zerfließt es und dann ist es einfach nur so ein Mikrofon. Einmal so ein Alexa-artiges Mikrofon. Und man denkt, what? Weil das so ein Abhörgerät. Aus China. Und dann irgendwann, nee, aber dann kommt die Polizei und verhaftet sie und dann stellt sich raus, dass das Kind die ganze Zeit echt war, nur sie sich vorgestellt hat als Puppe, weil sie nicht damit klarkommen ist, dass sie ihr Kind getötet hat. Und dann der Black Mirror abspannt. Genau. Okay, Leute, mein nächstes Buch steht. Nice. Wisst du es uns? Ja. Pufo. Wahnsinn. Ja, es gibt noch das Kinderspielzeug, wo er das ganze Zeit mitgehört hat. Das war ein bisschen gruselig. Furby, oder? War das nicht Furby? Ich wollte immer einen Furby haben, ich durfte den nie haben. Ich hatte einen Furby und jetzt ist er in den Urteilen von Jan Böhmermann. Echt? Die gibt es ja jetzt nicht mehr, aber in diesem Video war mein Furby immer zu sehen. Ach so, das war dein Furby? Das war mein Furby. Der hat jetzt einen Job gefunden. Das war deiner. Habe ich für den 90er-Song damals hier abgegeben in der BTF und seitdem hat er hier gelebt. Was konnte der so sagen? Weiss ich gar nicht mehr. Nur drei, vier Sachen. Du konntest ihn auf den Bauch drücken, dann hat er Njaaa gemacht, dann konntest du den Finger in den Mund stecken, dann hat er meistens das gleiche Geräusch gemacht, manchmal ein anderes. Das war damals Hightech, also das war schon wow. Das war so krass, auch Tamagotchi und so, wo du so zwei Pixel gesehen hast, das war so geil. Vor allem, da war ich echt enttäuscht, weil ich war lange Zeit großer Fan vom Guinness-Buch der Weltrekorde und es war gerade die Zeit, wo Tamagotchi sehr riesen Hype war und jeder hat den Tamagotchi und dann war halt so Weltrekord für den ältesten Tamag. Und es war halt so ein 14-jähriges Mädchen, das halt einfach aus Zufall den ersten gekauft hat. Und ich war halt wirklich so völlig so, warum ist hier ein Fotograf? Hat so einen Blick, einfach so, ja, die ist jetzt halt die älteste. Und ich dachte, das ist doch ein Witz, das ist doch kein Rekord. Das ist halt einfach zufällig die, die den ersten bekommen hat. So ein Witz. Seitdem habe ich keinen Bezug mehr zum Guinnessuch der Rekorde. Da hast du verloren. Da habe ich wirklich den Bezug verloren. Da dachte ich mir, das ist doch lächerlich. Hast du mir denn Bock gehabt, selber einen Rekord aufzustellen? Ich habe überlegt, ich habe überlegt, aber mein Onkel hat mir tatsächlich abgeraten aktiv, weil er hat gesagt, dass er mal in der Zeitung gelesen hat, dass jemand die weiteste Distanz einer Erbse mit der Nase gerollt. Also du legst eine Erbse auf den Boden und rollst sie mit deiner Nase. Und es war wirklich im Kilometerbereich. Was? Und da hat er gesagt, ja, der hat da jetzt das wochenlang, monatelang trainiert. Und das alles nur für so einen kleinen Ausstand aus der Zeitung. Also Florentin, das lohnt sich nicht. Und ich, ja, gut, lange nicht, dann. Also ich wurde wirklich indoktriniert, nicht das Guinness-Buch der Rekorde anzustellen. Aber als Onkel musst du dich, glaube ich, festlegen. Du denkst dir, okay, ich habe eine Woche, ich habe diesen einen Familienausflug. Was kann ich dem Kind als Botschaft mitnehmen, das nützlich ist, aber jetzt auch nicht so umfangreich, weil keine Ahnung, dann irgendwie, wie man mit anderen Menschen umgeht. Wasch deine Eier vorbeiziehen. Ja genau, das ist ein kurzer, knackiger Beitrag, der was hilft. Aber ich mache nicht beim Guinness-Buch deine Karte mit einem sehr spezifischen Trick, Tipps fürs Leben. Ich würde das aber auch machen. Ich würde meine Kinder und meine Neffen ganz spezielle Sachen machen. So wirklich, du, egal was du machst, zieh in dem Zug nicht deine Schuhe aus. Mach's einfach nicht. Einfach, mach's nicht. Warum denn nicht? Du kannst die Playstation 2 haben, ich zeige dir die Filme, ich gebe dir meine Pornosammlung, ist mir alles egal. Aber zieh einfach im Zug die Schuhe nicht aus. Okay? Und dann sind wir cool. Und einfach so eine Botschaft. Und den Rest machen die Eltern, den ganzen harten Job machen die Eltern, aber ich bin der Onkel, der sagt, einfach nicht die Schuhe ausziehen. Ja. Finde ich gut.ieht nicht die Schuhe aus, wascht eure Eier, damit... Welchen Rekord könntest du brechen? Luft anhalten. Nee, da bin ich richtig schlecht drin. Die meisten Romane der Welt rausbringen. Nee, wahrscheinlich die meisten Gewinnspiele gewinnen, würde ich mal tippen. Wirklich? Hast du Glück? Also ich war wirklich immer, jetzt langsam hat mich das Glück so ein bisschen verlassen, aber ich war immer dafür bekannt, dass ich alle Gewinnspiele, an denen ich teilnehme, auch gewinne. Und das war eine Zeit lang wirklich wie so ein Fluch. Meine Freunde, die fanden mich total komisch irgendwann. Die haben schon so leicht so, was ist los mit dir? Weißt du, wir haben hier vier Hondas. Es geht, also für meine Verhältnisse damals, ich war halt Kind, war das halt alles mega krass.
Also einmal, erstmal habe ich natürlich ein Meet and Greet mit den No Angels gewonnen, die damals meine heftigste, krasse Lieblingsband waren, von denen ich wirklich alles hatte. Das war mega schlimm, an der Tag, an dem ich die getroffen habe, weil das war, also es war so, ich habe das gewonnen. Das sind ja keine Angels. Der Zeitablauf war so, ich habe es gewonnen, dann haben sie sich getrennt, dann haben sie sich getrennt und dann habe ich die getroffen. Oh nein. Und die mussten das aber vertraglich noch wahrnehmen und haben da schon so Burnout und schon so Tränensäcke unter den Augen, haben sich alle gehasst, waren mega schlecht drauf und dann wollten die auch kein Foto mit mir machen oder so. Ich habe nur so ein paar Autogramme auf so Posern bekommen und ich war wirklich am Boden zerstört.
Aber das ist ja genial, du warst in einem historischen Moment beteiligt.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich meine, Meeting, Greet mit den coolen Superstars hat jeder, aber du hast wirklich da diese zerbrochene Karriere erlebt.
Diese zerbrochenen Seelen.
Haben die sich vor dir gefässt?
Nee, gar nicht, aber die hatten absolut keine Lust auf, die haben nicht miteinander geredet, haben nur das Nötigste irgendwie gesagt und dann ein paar Autogramme gegeben und dann ja. Aber du bist ja immer noch nur Angels-Fan, also es wurde nicht entzaubert dadurch. Ja, ich bin halt auch einfach Fan von der Musik, Florenzi. Ach so, ja, ja, das Werk. Aber das war nur ein Gewinnspiel, was ich gewonnen habe. Es gab ja mal, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das noch kennt, aber es gab bei Viva eine Sendung, die hieß Interaktiv. Und da kamen jeden Tag andere Promis zu Gast und haben ein Gastgeschenk mitgebracht.
Und am Ende der Woche konnte man anrufen und wenn man alle Geschenke der Woche aufsagen konnte, hat man alles gewonnen. Und ich habe halt schon montags gesagt, diese Woche mache ich da mal mit, da werde ich sicher gewinnen. Und ich habe es auch zu meiner Freundin, aber in der Schule gesagt, du musst heute, am Freitag habe ich zu ihr gesagt, du musst heute mal Viva einschalten. Ich gewinne da heute die Stargeschenke. Und dann habe ich da halt wirklich bestimmt zwei, dreihundert Mal angerufen, jedes Mal so für einen Euro. Es war 2003, ich war gerade zwölf geworden. Was gewinnt dann dann noch, ist die Frage. Ja, pass auf, ich bin natürlich durchgestellt worden und war dann im Studio mit Mona Adebesi, die habe ich telefoniert. Und ich habe dann Sachen gewonnen, total krank einfach nur, unter anderem die Schuhe von Dieter Bohlen, der hat dann so sein Geschenk vergessen und dann haben die so gesagt, Dieter, was hast du uns als Gastgeschenk mitgebracht und er so, äh, meine Schuhe und hat sie so ausgezogen und schnell signiert und die habe ich dann gewonnen und dann so einen Fussball von Simply Red unterschrieben und so von allen Badmitten, von Westlife so eine Tasse und so und die ganzen Sachen und auch von da eine Kübel überquad was dabei.
Wer jetzt als Frau in Kanada lebt, hat die Bunte gesagt. Ich habe aber noch nicht recherchiert, ob es nicht stimmt oder wie Rooks.
Aber hast du die Sachen noch? Ja, jetzt kommt es nämlich. Ich war gerade zwölf geworden und als ich sie dann aufgelegt habe, war mir klar, wow, okay, du hast jetzt nächste Woche kommen hier drei grosse Pakete an mit exklusiven Sachen von Promis, von denen du keinen gut findest, wirklich keinen. Und habe dann in diesem Wissen, schon bevor die Sachen überhaupt da waren, ein Ebay-Konto angelegt und da habe ich mich da wirklich komplett krank alles, wirklich alles, was ich bekommen habe, verscherbelt und halt auch aber wirklich gut. Ich habe gemerkt, okay, zum Beispiel die Schuhe von Dieter Bohlen liefen ganz gut, das hat eine Schwede irgendwie für 300 Euro gekauft, 300 Euro, wenn man 12 ist, ist mega krass, 300 Euro so, habe ich mich voll gefreut, aber so Sachen wie der Fussball von Simply Red oder die Tasse von Westlife, die Fans sind ja international und die wussten natürlich nicht von dieser Sendung, die in Deutschland ausgestattet wurde, wie sollen die wissen, dass bei Ebay jetzt gerade ein Fussball versteigert wird. Also bin ich in die Foren reingegangen. Ich habe mich angemeldet auf Englisch und habe überall in diesen ganzen Foren mit zwölf krank und habe mich dann da reingefuchst und habe denen allen gesagt, geht mal auf diesen Link. Gestern war die Band Westlife bei Interaktiv. Habe dann alles bei E-Mail verkauft und bin mega reich geworden. Wie viel hast du Instagram so gemacht damit? Ich weiß es nicht, aber es war glaube ich bestimmt 1000 Euro oder so. Halt wenn man drei, zwölf war. Wahnsinn, das würde ich jetzt sagen. Es war so viel Geld, dass ich mir sogar selber davon eine Konsole kaufen durfte und ich durfte keine Konsolen haben. Das ist fast die Telefonrechnung wieder raus alles. Ja, deswegen habe ich richtig Ärger bekommen. Aber ich habe eine Sache behalten und das war der Lippenstift von Jeannette Biedermann. Echt? Ja. Hast du die doch zu Hause rumgelegt? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Behalten die sich oder schimmeln die irgendwann so wieder? Das ist mega eklig. Das war schon eklig, als er ankam, weil er schon so halb runter war, halt so richtig benutzt. Und ich weiß nicht, aus welchem Grund ich das behalten habe, aber ich fand es, glaube ich, aber wenn irgendwann die Klontechnik weiter fortgeschritten ist, dann bist du die Erste, die sagt Hallo! Einmal Jeannette Biedermann. Ich finde nach diesen Jurassic Park Einspieler vor, wie die aus der Mücke, die in Bernstein ist, und du machst dann den Jeannette Biedermann Park auf, wo überall so verschiedene weirde Jeannette Biedermanns rumlaufen. Da wird nichts passieren, das ist überhaupt kein Problem, die sind gut eingesperrt, die Janet Biedermanns. Dann kommt Jeff Goldblum und sagt, life finds a way, life finds a way. Jetzt müsste man die Indiana Jones, Quatsch, die Jurassic Park Musik mit irgendeinem Janet Biedermanns Song covern. Ja, niemand kennt Janet Biedermanns Songs. Was macht die eigentlich? Ich glaube, die ist eine Karriere beendet. Aber was macht man dann, wenn man die Karriere dann beendet hat? Das ist so die Frage. Und man hat so Mittel gut verdient, weil man war halt in Deutschland irgendwie für zwei, drei Jahre ein Promi. Was macht man denn dann? Ich glaube, da gibt es wirklich dann so die richtige Baumarkteröffnung, Stadtfest, Mallorca, da gibt es dann eigentlich auch noch nichts. Aber kann man davon leben? Ich mache mir so ein bisschen Sorgen um Edward Snowden, weißt du, der, ich meine, was kann der noch machen? Obier eröffnen. Ne, sein Kapital war, er wusste etwas und hat das jetzt veröffentlicht. That's it. Das ist ausgeschöpft. Also ich meine, der kennt sich ja immer noch gut aus. Er ist immer mit so Zeitungen vor, sich mit so ausführenden Augen, die Augen irgendwo und will wieder was wissen. Ja, aber ich meine, der kann jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, irgendwie ein Kinderbuch schreiben oder so. Vielleicht hat der aber auch so ein Management mit so einem Zehnjahresplan, die den für den gemacht haben. Ja, wahrscheinlich, dass sie den nochmal richtig hohes Braus bringen, irgendwie dann so als Kinderstar für die Pelodien. Was sind deine Stärken, Edward? Ich kann gut Geheimnisse ausplaudern. Benno der Spionbär von Edward Snowden. Okay. Er hat so einen ganz schlechten Film. Oder du rufst Call-Sender an? Ist er Snowden hier? Hallo? So ein Sandra Bullock-Film, schmacht er. So ein Statist im Hintergrund. Mitmach jetzt! Edward Snowden, der rumgelaufen ist. Der muss ein gutes Leben führen. Können wir den mal einladen? Ich glaube schon. Das ist gar nicht so unüblich. Skype macht er glaube ich nicht. Ach stimmt. Die wissen zu viele Daten. Ja, stimmt. Was macht der denn? Telegram. Irgendwas Russisches bestimmt, die haben da bestimmt krasse. Ja, Freema oder Telegram oder so. Ja, Freema wahrscheinlich dann so. Dass er um die Welt geschickt wird. Vielleicht, ich meine, wir hatten jetzt heute dich als Gast, das heißt wir haben jetzt erst wieder drei Jahre keinen Gast, weil wir sehr... Und fünf Jahre keine Frau. Ja, und erstmal Edward Snow. Es wird auch langsam zu viel. Jetzt kommt auch auf, wir hatten schon ganz viele Frauen zu Gast. Das Feminismus-Ufo. Ich dachte, wir kriegen mal ein bisschen Lob von dir dafür, dass wir auch ganz viele Frauen zu Gast haben. Ich finde es gut, dass ihr viele Frauen zu Gast habt und dass eure Mitarbeiterin Thais eine Frau war. Ich bin sehr gespannt auf euren Podcast. Ich glaube, das kann wirklich was sein. Die ist sehr interessant, kann man sich gut mit ihr unterhalten. Ich glaube, da könnt ihr wirklich was schlagen. Ich habe mich immer gesträubt, davor einen Podcast selber zu machen, weil ich immer denke, das kann doch nicht interessant sein. Hör auf. Ja, aber du hast auch ein Buch geschrieben. Ja, das stimmt. Ich höre immer, ich muss leider sagen, ich höre nie Podcasts. Also wirklich nie, ausser ein und das ist das philosophische Radio mit Jürgen Wiebicke. Mega. Das ist mega. Ja, mag ich auch sehr gerne. Kann es sein, dass es gerade richtig hart regnet? Draußen, ja, es klingt ein bisschen so. Jetzt kommen die Ratten rein. Ich wollte gerade sagen. Heute war auch schon so ganz spül draußen, man wartet immer auf diesen Wolkenbogen und denkt so, komm jetzt, komm schon. Aber ich muss dringen ins Bett, ich habe die Nacht nicht geschlafen. Warum, wie ist das hier? Hey, wo-w3! Ich war echt zu aufgeregt so. Warum denn? Ich war zu aufgeregt. Ich habe im World of Warcraft 3 Editor mir meinen eigenen Helden gebaut und dann hast du noch so viel im Kopf und dann liegst du um vier im Bett und dann hast du aber noch im Kopf so, ich mache noch die Fähigkeiten und ich programmiere das so und dann denkst du dir irgendwann so, ja, ich stehe jetzt einfach wieder auf, weil ich kann nicht schlafen, so, ich muss das jetzt noch umsetzen, was ich im Kopf habe. Ja, so, das ist total belanglos, aber du hast es noch im Kopf. Ich habe das sehr kompliziert, seinen eigenen Helden anzulegen. Es ist tatsächlich sehr kompliziert. Ich habe auch, glaube ich, häufiger Charaktere angelegt als gespielt, also das Spiel dann gespielt. Aber es gibt nichts Schöneres, als selbst den Schlafrhythmus in die hand zu nehmen und zu sagen so ne ich schlafe nicht ich mache jetzt ich kaufe mir jetzt einfach sie acht sieben acht stunden zack machst so und schon hast du acht stunden mit energie gekauft ja klar du zahlst aber trotzdem das ist zeit wie ein kredit ich glaube ich würde ziemlich viel Geld dann aber dafür ausgeben.
Angenommen. In den acht Stunden, die du hast.
Nee, in einer Welt, in der man das verkaufen könnte.
Du hast doch gesagt, man könnte die Energie quasi kaufen.
Er meinte, ja.
Also du kannst dir kaufen, dass du nicht schlafen musst.
Ja, da würde ich sehr viel Geld für ausgeben.
Tausend Euro die Nacht.
Weil du ja automatisch mehr Zeit hast, zu kreieren.
Tausend Euro die Nacht. Wirklich? Ja, nee, nicht pro Nacht. Das müsste dann schon so ein Abo sein. Das wäre geil. Ja gut, pro Woche zahlt sie dann vielleicht nur noch so 800 pro Nacht. Das ist schon viel. Das wäre auch immer eine geile Black Mirror-Folge, wenn man nicht mehr schlafen muss, was man dann in der Menschheit macht, was man in der Gesellschaft macht, wenn man nicht mehr schlafen muss. Unsere ganzen Tage sind darauf ausgelegt, dass die irgendwann vorbei sind. Ja, oder irgendwann die Erde kommt aus dem Gleichgewicht und rotiert schneller und der Tag ist nur noch halb so lang. Und die Nacht aber dann auch? Die Nacht ist dann auch halb so lang, sondern es hat einfach doppelt so viele Sonnenaufgänge und Untergänge. Es wäre auch geil, wenn die Nacht doppelt so lang ist und der Tag halb so lang. Aber ist die Nacht nicht eh schon ein bisschen zu lang? Was? Ich finde die Nacht zu kurz. Ich finde die Nacht auch zu kurz. Aber du gehst doch ins Bett, wenn es schon dunkel ist. Ja, aber ich werde schon wach, weil die scheiss Vögel schon wach sind. Es ist verschoben. Das ist einfach nicht gesund. Nee, die Nacht ist aber nicht viel zu kurz, sondern ein bisschen zu kurz. Aber ein bisschen zu kurz, ja. Fast perfekt. Ein Detail, sorry. Ich bin ja auch hier gross geworden, ich bin ja ein Erdenjung, weißt du? Ja, Erdenjung. Aber Alter, Erde, no place like Earth. Nee, mein liebster Planet, ich bin ja auch gross geworden und so. Ist das ein Begriff, Erdenjung? Nein. Noch nicht. Earth, sweet Earth. Vielleicht jetzt, I'm an Earth Boy. Deswegen wünsche ich mir einfach so eine Stunde mehr, wäre cool. Naja. Vielen Dank, dass du da warst, Julia. Vielen Dank, Julia. Mega cool. Ist es jetzt schon vorbei? Jetzt ist es schon vorbei. Wir haben es schon mehr gemacht als sonst. Aber es geht natürlich weiter, wenn du deinen Podcast startest. Wir sind natürlich die Ersten, die euch darüber informieren, wann es losgeht. Es wird keinen Podcast geben, aber ihr könnt ein Buch gewinnen. Fünf Bücher. Schreibt auf jeden Fall an, das kann jetzt eingefügt werden im Nachhinein, und für alle, die kein Buch gewinnen, kauft es euch verdammt noch mal. Das Leben ist eines der härtesten, fantastisches Buch von Julia Becker. Einen fantastischen Humor, wo ich finde, habe ich schon im Podcast sogar immer gelobt, weil Humor auch fantastisch raus, der rauskommt. Und das ist ein sehr, sehr eigener Humor. Und einen sehr, sehr eigenenil. Und das habe ich damals immer schon geschätzt und das freut mich auch immer noch, dass man das lesen kann. Danke. Übrigens hast du auch die grösste Inspiration damals für die Kurzgeschichten geliefert, was du gesagt hast, this is a book von Demetri Martin, was ich mir gekauft habe und dachte, ich will genau so ein Buch schreiben. Weil ich dir ein Buch empfohlen habe. Du hast ja jetzt die ganzen Kurzgeschichten noch, oder so wie ich es jetzt verstanden habe, was so eine Geschichte... Ja, bis dahin, wo ich gekommen bin natürlich. Es sind irgendwie fünf Kurzgeschichten, die habe ich noch. Gut, aber vielleicht hausst du noch mal so zwei, drei oder so. Oder wir geben dir einen Tausi und wir hauen dir als Rubrik hier im Podcast-Ufo immer mal wieder eine Kurzgeschichte für die Lerbecker raus. Ja, eine Lesung. Dafür kriegst du eine Nacht. Für eine Nacht würde ich euch die geben. Eine Nacht pro Geschichte.
Ja.
Machen wir.
Ja, perfekt.
Perfekt, gut.
Na dann, freut euch auf mehr von Julia Becker, ansonsten haut rein, macht's gut.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Und wir heben jetzt ab.
Muss ich das auch machen?
Ja.
Kann ich nicht.
Ciao.